the circuit court of fairfax county is
now in session
presiding please
good morning
all right do we have any preliminary
matters before the jury comes out
sure
good one
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
is
[Applause]
those are relatives all relatives
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
still under oath okay all right next
question thank you your honor
amber when did the first act of physical
violence by mr depp occur
objection aston answered
no overworld
that would have been early 2012.
and how did you determine this
i
reviewed my therapy objection hearsay
i i i she hasn't even answered it you're
all right i'll allow the answer
by reviewing my therapist notes
objection
i'll sustain the objection
but it's not offered to prove the truth
of the matter asserted it's it's
explaining
what she looked at i'll sustain the
objection okay
when did you earlier believe the first
act of physical violence occurred
well i had
always believed
up until recently that it was it had
started later
that the violence started around early
2013
on early 2012.
now you testified earlier that the first
act of physical violence by mr depp
related to the winona wyno tattoo do you
recall that testimony i do okay
is that
does that change your testimony
realizing that this is earlier was this
in fact still this is the first act
objection leading
sustained
what was what was the first act
objection asked and answered sustained
how do you remember the first act of
violence
well you never forget it that's how i
remember it it
changes your life forever you never
forget the first time someone hits you
like that
i just had the date wrong
okay
and
how did how is it that you think you got
the date wrong
objection calls for speculation
overruled
um
i'm embarrassed to say i think i would
have liked to believe that the period of
time
in which i had to fall in love with
johnny in which we fell in love and he
was sober and he wasn't violent to me
lasted for a lot longer than it did
i think i would have liked to have
believed that
i
i wasn't hit so early in the
relationship and still stayed he was
also sober for a period in 2012 which
was a peaceful time for us
in which we fell in love so i
had kind of
allowed myself i guess uh to forget
that the beginning of that period 2012
before he got sober was
was really violent and chaotic as well
i i'm embarrassed to say that
now you testified that the police were
called multiple times other than the may
21 2016
what other occasions were there where
the police were called
they were called in december of 2011
they were called in 2012.
they were called uh in 2013 in march by
the landlord
um
they i had sought advice from laurel
anderson as to whether i should call the
police objection hearsay
sustain
okay
when you filed the domestic violence
temporary restraining order how many
acts of abuse did you allege at that
time
i gave
the last couple i believe
last two incidents maybe three and why
didn't you tell of all the acts of abuse
at that time
i was following advice from my counsel
okay how many instances of abuse were
included in the uk trial
uh there were 14 acts of physical abuse
and violence and three acts of sexual
abuse
and why were those 17 included in the uk
trial
well i was not a party um a direct party
i was a witness so it was whatever their
council uh the sun council chose okay
when is the first time you were called
upon to provide a detailed accounting
of as many times as you could recall of
physical and sexual abuse by mr depp
objection hearsay
i don't that's not hearsay your honor
i'm asking her when she was called upon
to do so the objection is hearsay right
but it's not offered to prove the truth
of the matter asserted and it's just
asking for date
all right overall thank you
a few months ago february and
2022 this year um was the first time i
was asked to to do so other than a cold
in a deposition okay
and when you were asked to provide those
what did you do to be able to prepare
that account in that full accounting
well i had the benefit of my therapist
objection hearsay so uh your honor
she's not saying what the therapist said
i'm just i'll overrule the objective
thank you go ahead i looked at my
therapist notes at the benefit of those
notes which we had received in february
as well as i reviewed calendars photos
text messages
my journals my diaries
of which there are many
i put all of those together it took a
lot of time
to be able to you know adequately
refresh my recollection and fill in the
details over the
course of the five years we were
together and
what did you do when you put that all
together
i
i kind of
filled in
and collected all of these various
pieces of information
and gave a fuller account as best i
could
for each uh incidence of violence that i
had record of um i think it was called
an interrogatory
in this case in this case all right
excuse me did you sign that under oath i
did okay and it was provided to counsel
for mr deb it was okay uh and was it a
pretty lengthy document
it was far too long
and
how is it that you didn't just remember
all of those events like this
that's
that's not how
your memory or my memory works you know
we were together for five years almost
four and a half
and uh it was a very
violent chaotic
at times very loving
emotional
uh
relationship so as
as anyone can imagine there was a lot
going on and
unfortunately the violence became
almost normal
especially towards the end it was just
it's it's hard to even it's hard to say
that now but the violence was
almost normal and
you know your brain does with trauma
what it does
puts it away best you can so i was
i was um
frankly i was shocked to see um
a lot of the information presented to me
um through my therapist notes because
she was taking him objection your honor
hearsay all right i'll sustain your
objection okay we'll move past that
there what the therapist said in her
notes okay now there's one more you also
provided the declaration in this case
early on
do you recall that trying to move the
case to california yes there was a
declaration in 2019 all right and did
you describe some of the events of
violence in that declaration objection
leading uh what if anything was said
about violent acts in that declaration
i was taking the advice of my counsel we
had um it was to get it moved i believe
okay and
was there
did you include all of them no objection
leading
no i did not include all of the
incidents of violence that was not the
point of making this declaration
we were making this declaration and
effort to move it to california because
as hard as it is to go through this sort
of trial
as it is
it's even harder to do so in a place
that neither johnny nor i are connected
to
okay
now you testified earlier about guitars
and you said you've never played a
guitar
have you ever played a guitar player in
a movie
you could say i posed with the guitar i
it turns out i am an unteachable
okay
i'm going to take you to the tape
recordings why did you and mr depp start
taping each other
well at first it was
not at first it was meant to be a
a way to get to the heart of our some of
our communication issues
in order to do
to discover in a therapeutic fashion
kind of what was
some of our issues in our
communication okay now we heard an audio
tape earlier during this trial in which
you said the word
couch
repeatedly can you please explain to the
jury what that meant
yes
couch was a word that we had been uh
given that we decided upon rather
objection hearsay
just tell me tell us what mr depp said
about this
uh that it it was a safe word it was
meant to be a safe word like a word uh
like truce
where you put down
the proverbial guns and you say truce
we're not fighting anymore couch was
supposed to be a word that
you used that we used
as a truce i don't want to fight anymore
you win let's let's stop this
that was the mention of couch which you
heard earlier in a recording
now what if any discussions did you have
with mr depp about
threatening to divorce each other or
threatening to leave objection calls for
hearsay to the extent of calls for
misheard statements i'm asking for
discussions with mr depp
still her just tell us what mr depp said
don't tell us what you said
can you repeat the question yeah yes
what did mr depp say in your discussions
about the use of the term threatening to
divorce or threatening to leave each
other objection leading overrule
well
johnny would always say
the only way out of this was death
but in fights in
in particularly heated ones
we had found you know we were using
divorce in the fight
in some of our heated fights
we tried not to um but that kind of
deteriorated after the december
incident that i got beat up pretty badly
and and after that point it was used a
lot more often
okay
now march 26 2015
this is after the us first australia
trip and after the staircase incident
i'm going to ask michelle can you bring
up depp
exhibit
371 a
this is a tape recording and it's going
to be
at
one minute
one colon zero one to two colon two nine
could you say that times again yes it's
uh one colon zero one two
two colon two nine and if we could i
don't know whether you had turned up
that volume i know it's hard to hear
these is this an evidence already um
this i'm moving it into evidence your
honor but these are the tape recordings
between the two which i think we had
agreed is there any objection 371a
your honor if you just give me a moment
to confirm there's no other voices
it's not in evidence your honor so could
you please confirm that there are no
other voices this
i will confirm that this and it's dep's
exhibit right mr dep's exactly 371 a
then any objection no objection
371 a in evidence
thank you
and we may need to
sami if i could just if you listen and
we may need to turn that volume up
sometimes your control is a little bit
better than what we have max
i see somebody who's changing always
into different versions
of a person that i recognize for a week
and then he slips
and he disappears
and then i get
a different version of him you get the
insecure scared version of him
that lashes out
in a different medium every time
so if it's
adderall junkie johnny
then he's abusive and he's going he's a
timer he's mean he's reactionary and
he's incendiary and anything i do him
saying
his cause
for violence or anger if i speak to him
honestly he dropped me from the heart
i'm yelling at him
if i argue back with him the number
pieces
if i don't say anything then i am
dismissive or absent or it's found or
somewhere else
if i
engage with
because if i look at him the wrong way
he's a problem
if i say the wrong thing god knows what
it is
i'm the problem
that's the guy who's on a bunch of
[ __ ] speed
what did you mean
when you were saying that to mr deb
that
no matter
my perception was that no matter what i
did
no matter
what i did to de-escalate walk away from
him to confront him to try to
nothing i did made a difference
nothing i did changed his rage at me
nothing i did changed the violence
towards me nothing i did calmed him down
and i was constantly doing a juggling
act of what kind of version of johnny i
was dealing with
there were different versions of him and
they were drastically different from one
another and even more so than them being
different from one another
they didn't even sometimes remember
what the other version did or said
they acted almost like independent
versions of this person depending on
what combination of drugs and alcohol he
was on
that's what i was trying to express to
him it's just
the futility of me responding and
successfully and the futility of trying
to constantly negotiate with him
and the substances he was on at the time
i'm going to take you to april 15 2015
the premiere of when i live my life over
again
what if anything did you do for that
premiere
i believe that premiere was in new york
city it was a small independent film i i
shot i went back to new york to
attend the premiere michelle can you
bring up defendants exhibit 421 please
does this accurately depict the scene
portrayed in this picture
yes your honor i'm going to move the
admission of defendants exhibit 421 any
objection no objection all right 421 in
evidence may we publish to the jury
thank you
amber could you please describe
for the jury what this picture is
uh that is a picture of me
a
few months i believe this is april of
2015 so it's a few months after
the march incident that happened in
australia
early yeah early march in which
uh johnny held me down on the
countertops and my arms were cut on the
glass and
and in that
attack and if we could draw attention to
your arm there
are those scars
what are those please describe for the
jury what those are
those are scars that i obtained while
johnny was um strangling me and
assaulting me on the countertop in
australia okay
michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 423 please
and does this accurately portray the
scene
yes that's uh hold on a second i'm going
to move the admission of defendants 423
please
no objection 423 in evidence
thank you may we publish
all right and please describe to the
jury what this shows
uh it is a picture of me on a red carpet
you can see my scars
even though i have makeup on them
they're a bit harder to cover
because they're rather fresh
okay
now
after this in april of 2015 you returned
to australia with mr deb did you not
objection leading
overruled a lot thank you
yes we did okay and and
tell the jury about that trip
well after
after johnny was able to get
clean off of the coke and the other
drugs enough to get the hand surgery he
needed
there commenced a period of time of
sobriety for johnny he
his doctor had fired him and then came
on when johnny agreed to get clean
objection hearsay non-responsive
all right
don't don't say what i mean we've
already had your honor we've already had
the testimony from dr kipper but don't
say what dr kipper did just just tell
the other part just don't say what
somebody else said
so there was this period of sobriety
after that um and johnny was very
committed to being clean and sober and
i thought
we had finally done it
we finally did it we were through it and
we were never going back meaning it was
he was going to be clean and sober for
good this time and we had a wonderful
period of you know we fell back in love
or
deeper in love than we were before it
seemed if things were so good
we were talking about a future again we
were talking about having kids
i mean when johnny wasn't using it was
so peaceful we had such a nut we had a
good time together we went back to
australia like that in that state
and had
a few months we even had my parents come
and visit us in australia and we were
talking about babies and about buying a
farm and you know about looking for
homes in california we were
in a really
beautiful peaceful period it was
wonderful
it was wonderful
now how did you did you stay at the same
place that you did the earlier time
in australia we went back to a very
remodeled
version of that home i mean remodeled
very cleaned up version of that home
uh same walls same structure but looked
a bit different as you can imagine
how did you feel going back to that home
given what had happened in march early
march
you know the
the home
the home isn't the problem
you know you're
if you're living
in domestic violence you don't just not
go home you know you don't
just not go into the kitchen just
because you were slapped in that kitchen
people living in domestic violence live
in their homes
it's that's almost
you know the home isn't the problem
that's the normal part of your home and
for me
you know johnny was my home
where we were a couple was my home
and that home was often really violent
but it wasn't the structure itself it
was johnny
and when we went back to australia that
home johnny
was in a
completely different you know he had
done a complete
180
clean sober present
calm
we were peaceful i mean
any of the the gripes and the problems
that he
seemed to have about me um went away
when he was sober
and so we had to really
we we managed to go back to that same
house
but in a very different way it felt very
different
june 16 2015 the magic mike tour where
did you go for that tour
while i was in australia i got the call
for that press tour and went to europe
for the press tour for that movie
and um
you know i was nervous because problems
arise when i'm having to work when i
leave objection non-responsive
i was still responsible well sustained
objection next question michelle can you
please bring up defendants exhibit 447.
i'm going to ask you first does this
accurately portray the scene depicted
yes
i'm going to move the admission of
defendants exhibit 447. the objection
447 in evidence you can publish
thank you
and michelle if you could zoom in just a
little bit closer
amber could you tell the jury about this
picture
uh yes that's me on the red carpet
um promoting the magic mic movie i was
in um you can see
the scars on my body on my arms okay you
can't
see everything of course but
okay
and michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 449
and amber does this
accurately depict the scene portrayed
uh yes it does your honor i'm going to
move the admission of defendants 449
objection 449 in evidence
and amber could you please describe to
the jury what this portrays
uh this is uh
you can see the scars on my arm from
that attack
also around
this time um
johnny was calling me on the on the
phone
before and after you know while i was
doing these press events and sometimes i
would be on the phone with him
um
kind of managing
accusations about why i didn't pick up
sooner didn't text back sooner and um
sometimes
i
actually on this tour many times uh had
to delay getting out of the car or
objection non-responsive
i i'll i'll ask that how did mr deb
react to your going on this press tour
uh he was very upset with me i just
remember crying on the phone with him a
lot
and having to hang up to do do press
events all right thank you
now i'm going to take you to the
southeast asia train trip that was your
honeymoon trip correct yes it was okay
and that was
july 25 2015.
yes it was okay michelle i'm going to
ask you to bring up plaintiff's exhibit
162. it's already into evidence
mr mcgivern testified that he took this
picture in july of 2013. would you agree
objection mistakes prior testimony
that's exactly what he testified too
is that is that correct
uh i believe i i believe malcolm conley
took this on on the eastern i mean on
the orient express malcolm conley not
travis mcgivern i believe it was malcolm
on that trip with us yes okay and was it
in 2013 or was it 2015. it was in 2015.
okay july and
please describe if you can what
transpired during this trip
well the uh
the train
trip itself
was
was peaceful
up until
johnny wanted to start drinking brown
alcohol he had already started drinking
champagne when i returned from the press
tour that's what he was he was drinking
wine and champagne
um
and um
when i
s when he wrapped on pirates five the
plan was for us to do this honeymoon
i you know i was walking a bit on
eggshells because i know a pattern but i
was not wanting to accept that it was
that we had gone back
um to a pattern at all and so we were on
this train
uh and on the last night we were on the
train
um
after this was taken this photo
um
johnny and i got in an argument about
him wanting to be
allowed meaning wanting him
him wanting me to agree to him drinking
liquor
and being okay with it
and an argument
followed that in the um in our in our
sleeping car
uh johnny
uh slapped me across the face and held
me up by the
kind of got a hold of my neck and pushed
me up against the wall of the
cart
it was a small and narrow sleeper cart
and there were two beds one on each side
he had me up against the wall while he
was standing on the floor in between the
beds and i was on the bed kind of half
kneeling half standing trying
to get his arms off my neck and he was
squeezing my neck against the railway
car for what felt like
a very long time and every time he kind
of would pull me away from the side of
the car he'd
slam me up again
slam me up against the wall and i
remember looking down at him and trying
to get his arms
off of my neck
and i remember thinking
that
he could
he could not even mean to kill me you
know i remember being scared that he
wouldn't even mean to do it
and kind of looking down at him because
i was a slightly above him
as he was standing on on the ground and
kind of clawing at him trying to get him
to you know his arms away from my neck
i remember
i had um
at one point you ripped the top of my
shirt i don't really remember what it
was but i remember
i had a breast exp exposed
at some point i
pulled his lapel of his shirt and he
rips the shirt off
of him and wraps it around my neck
and um
that's how i woke up
the next morning actually i woke up with
it still around my neck
and with a giant knot in the back of my
head
did you keep a diary at that time
yes i did michelle can you bring up
defendants exhibit 461.
objection hearsay
uh
it is a diary your honor and i will just
ask her some questions about it rather
than trying to admit it into evidence at
this point
right
um i'll wait for the question go ahead
what if
anything
do you recall about
recording what transpired on that train
objection hearsay i'm just asking her
whether she did i'm not asking what she
recorded all right i'll out go ahead
overall
i wrote about what happened that night
the next morning
thank you
now
was did mr deb suffer any injuries on
that trip
not that i saw i have a lot of pictures
from that trip and he's uninjured okay
thank you you can take that down
michelle thank you
now i'm going to keep you in july of
2015 and michelle i'm going to ask you
to bring up
depp
exhibit 390a it's a recording
and i'm going to be asking about from
3 colon 30
to 4 colon 12.
i'm going to move the admission your
honor that's another recording between
mr depp and ms heard there's nobody else
it's
what number was it it's plaintiffs it's
uh 390a okay any objection to 390a
um
i'm sorry
may we approach okay
any objection then no objection all
right 390a in evidence
saw you doing it earlier whatever
it's fine it's secretive
it's deceitful you already [ __ ]
you've got you had trouble with me
before
when you said to me that you didn't feel
like you were told when i was recording
you so please stop
you didn't please stop
you did not please stop [ __ ]
acknowledge what i'm saying before you
keep making demands you are not a school
teacher shut the [ __ ] up listen to me
and then you can [ __ ] respond
understand
you ain't nobody's [ __ ] mom you ain't
no school teacher don't [ __ ] pretend
to be authoritative with me okay you
don't exist
what were you discussing in that
call
we were discussing uh whether or not
it was all right uh to record each other
without the other's permission
and uh
johnny said it didn't matter anymore
the requirement of of that permission
from me i was trying to say hey
we agreed
okay
let's go to august 2015
please describe your relationship with
mr deb in that time frame
you said august august 2015.
uh august
2015 was a very difficult time following
the brief honeymoon we had uh
johnny's use continued well it started
again is a better way to describe it
and
lo and behold so did our disagreements
coincidentally not quits not
coincidentally
i got an offer to do a job which was
already a problem
or problematic
i was considering working on a tv series
that had james franco in it i was asked
if i would meet with the
people who are making the show objection
hearsay it's not offered to prove the
truth of the matter overrule thank you
and
so i was considering taking that job
and it
there was a possibility it would require
brief nudity
which i knew i would have to negotiate
down but
obviously that was a problem for johnny
didn't want me to do that didn't want me
to work
and um
and frankly i needed to
and uh there was another
film i had coming out that i had
previously shot it's called london
fields
it was a source of a lot of fighting
between us because of the sexuality in
the role
it was a constant negotiation between
myself and the filmmakers they made a
film
and johnny hur told me that he had heard
about it was unhappy with some of what
he had heard he was unhappy with me
having
done a sex scene in it that he claimed i
didn't tell him about
i did not actually film the scene he was
speaking of um he demanded that we watch
the
a screener of it which is a like a
a version of the film before it's
released
we got one sent to where we were at the
time johnny chateau in france it's in a
remote part of france
and once again we're in this remote
place and
we're screening this film that i
appeared in and there was a scene a sex
scene in that movie
that started
before
johnny freaked out
because it it looked like me
it they had used a body double
unbeknownst to me without my permission
they used a body double to do a sex
scene
so i have an incredibly jealous man who
already
is upset with me for breaking the rule
that i had a sex scene on top of that
i'm telling him it wasn't me i didn't
shoot that scene
and you can imagine
um
how upset he was it was um irate and was
calling me a liar
[ __ ] among other things and we had this
that combined with the fact that i had
even entertained doing this job that
involved james franco
was a
a pressure cooker
um
i called it a week of hell uh later
i objection hearsay
johnny at one point um slapped me in the
face in our bedroom in the chateau that
we were staying in
at another moment he
punched me across the jaw
at one point
he kind of either pushed or or through
it's hard to describe to you which of
those two it is because
i i can't tell you i just know i went
flying into this old church furniture
i later thought i had a concussion
uh it was the first time i thought i i
had sustained a concussion
um
and that's
i wrote about it later
now
did did there come a time in this time
frame that you found a folder on mr
depp's computer
yes what was it labeled
it was on johnny's um
opening pages desktop it said no fun for
jd in all caps
and what was in that folder
it was a pic it was a collection of
pictures of me from various red carpets
starting on the press tours that i had
been on
um where i zoomed in pictures of
what he thought was you know like
inappropriate clothing side boob
cleavage any time i moved objection
calls for speculation
all right i'll sustain as to what she
believes it was okay
what pictures were in that folder that
we have seen today
the ones i saw of the
kind of rose cold gold dress and the red
dress we're both in that file
now what if anything did mr depp
say to you or ask you about how you got
those cuts on your arms
nothing
what if anything has mr deb ever said to
you or asked you about any injuries that
you've sustained over those years
johnny's obviously never asked me how i
got any of those scars
did you ever witness mr deb uh
self-injuring himself
uh often he did that often please tell
the jury about that what did he do i
first started
um uh
i first started
i can't tell you what i told my
therapist but
um
i almost called 9-1-1 in new york in
2014
august of 2014 i believe
because i thought he had done himself an
injury
he often in fight would cut his arms
or hold a knife to his chest
or
draw blood
superficially superficially at first but
uh later
like in 2016 especially as our
relationship was ending
um oh he also puts cigarettes out on
himself
he'd flick them at me
and once or twice tried to put one out
on me but mostly he would do it while
screaming at me
he once did it right in front of me
screaming
at my face as he as he
put the cigarette out on his cheek
now i'm going to take you to september
15 2015 and myself we can bring up a deb
exhibit that's plaintiff's exhibit 345 a
this is another audio recording and it's
five colon five four
two seven colon five five
i'd like to move the admission any
objection
no objection sorry 345a in evidence
thank you
if you can play michelle please
i'm whoever's going to pour you on i'm
not going you should
i don't have any control over how much
you drink
but you don't have any control over
whether i tell you the truth enough
have you changed lately yeah you've
changed
your truth is really interesting too
okay yeah well i'm the first person
that's noticed so i can go downstairs
okay
yes your escape route i see
it
no of course 15 minutes just like last
time
just like last time
i had to pull you up
when you passed out naked in the
bathroom in there
did you pull me out
you tried to
yeah
[Music]
did you feel sad it didn't get in tight
by pounding on the door waking up every
15 minutes and then falling asleep next
to the door i could hear you snore in
case that you vomited i could call a
mess if you ever stop snoring
i thought you would choke on your own
vomit which is very likely with you
yes you do vomit a lot in your sleep
oh it's news to you
then this is affecting you a lot more
than i thought it was
um
[Music]
[Music]
please
explain to the jury what the issue was
in this particular tape recording
well
johnny at the time was
wanting to go and
drink
downstairs
at a bar and
we were talking about 15 minutes because
the last several times he had done that
it had been days and disappear on a
bender get really sick
and you know the drill by now having
heard enough from me um so
another issue that we were having at the
time or that he was having at the time
that affected me is that he would pass
out and vomit and vomited very very
regularly at this stage he was obviously
drinking again i'd given up
fighting with him on that at that stage
and what i had a habit of doing is
turning him over onto his side so he
doesn't choke on his own vomit
um it's very common for people who do
that to affixiate at least that's what i
understood so
the advice i got was to turn him to his
side put a pillow underneath his back
and turn his his head so that he didn't
affixiate
and
one time i was doing that and he swung
at me and
i told medical
and the advice after i got their advice
i realized i can't say what the advice
was but after i got that advice i
stopped doing
that i tried to as much as i could leave
him
uh and just be ready ready to call 9-1-1
or help if i heard him choking
and sometimes that happened behind
bathroom doors
well and that's going to take me to
september 27 2015 again depp that's
plaintiff's exhibit 356
a
and the recording is 31.07
to 32 30.
i'm going to move the admission your
honor
any objection to that
objection all right 36 356 a in evidence
thank you michelle thank you
why and that you punched me in the
[ __ ] thing and you stood in the face
and you said
no [ __ ] i didn't what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
and i watched you lie and then i just
punched you by the way you i'm sorry
that i didn't um punch you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
but you're not punched don't tell me
what it feels like to be punched you
know even a lot of fights been around a
long time i know no when you [ __ ]
have a closed fist punched you're not
hit i'm sorry i hit you like this but i
did not punch you i do not [ __ ] deck
you i [ __ ] was hitting you i don't
know what the motion of my actual hand
was but you're fine i did not hurt you i
did not punch you i was hitting you how
are your toes what am i supposed to do
do this how are you i'm not
yeah you did so i had to get the [ __ ]
out of there yes you did so you did the
right thing the big thing the you know
what you were admirable
every single time what what what's your
excuse when there's not a physical fight
then what's the excuse that
you're still being admirable right just
by
running away
amber please explain to the jury what's
transpiring in that audio recording what
that's about
well there's
there's two different
there's two different situations that
we're referencing in this fight two
different altercations between johnny
and i involved in the door
the first of which which we first start
talking about
where i'm talking about hitting him i am
talking about
what that conversation is about is about
the disparity
uh of this the disparity between johnny
and i in our physical fights the
disparity of
how he would proactively punch me
and i would have to resort to reactively
hitting him
i am talking about the difference
between a punch
which johnny did often
and me having to hit him in my defense
i know the difference between those two
and i'm highlighting the difference
between those two even if he wasn't
twice my size they're very different and
that's what i'm pointing out to him
the situation that that involved the
context of that is it happened in our
bedroom up in in penthouse 3 you've
heard us talk about that place and i was
trying to shut a door our bedroom door
actually i was trying to barricade
myself behind this door and johnny was
trying to get through the door he was
using his body and his limbs to try to
bust through the door as i was trying to
keep it closed because i knew what he
would do to me when he got to me on the
other side
and i was hitting his arms
his arms his body as he was trying to to
prevent me from closing the door
uh and that is a separate incident that
we later talk about in the second half
of that recording where we're talking
about my toes that involved a different
incident
which was a bathroom door and it was one
of those ones that he was passing out in
and i could hear him passing out or what
it sounded like to me behind the closed
doors passing out i heard a thud i heard
a lot of commotion i heard a glass break
and i hear what sounds like his body
falling against
the bathroom door i open it to check on
him as i was accustomed to doing at that
time
johnny violently reacted to me opening
the door pushed it against me it ran up
over my toes
and he angrily came around the side of
the door swinging at me i
naturally pushed the door off of my feet
responding to the pain
and also to the awareness the knowledge
that he was coming for me
johnny later
denied
well later he blamed me
and his
inability to understand what happened in
that he was
not in his right mind and he
misunderstood that interaction and tried
to blame me for starting a a physical
fight between us
and he even later went so far as to say
i wasn't even going to hit you
and um
that was the that was the second door
i
only can i only could respond
by trying to take accountability for
my actions in it what he understood my
actions were and my interpretation and
what i'm trying to say to him is look
i can only do my best to respond i was
in pain i was scared and i can't promise
you that when i'm scared and in pain
and i won't react thinking i know very
well what our situation is and what's
going to happen to me should i not react
thank you
so let's i'm going to play another clip
from that same
discussion and your honor would be
plaintiff's exhibit that's 5 356 b we
will call that and it would be from 1
colon 29 colon 27
to 1 colon 30 colon 07 and i'd like to
move the admission
all right any objection
no objection your honor all right 356b
in evidence thank you your honor
i can't promise you that i'll be perfect
i can't promise you i won't get physical
again god i [ __ ] sometimes get so mad
i lose it
i can [ __ ] promise you i'm you
need to i will leave you
it's fair i can't do it you know and i
think honestly if we hold each other
accountable to that it's fair
please explain to the jury what was
going on in that part of the discussion
that's the same conversation
where i am
as i was accustomed to doing i'm taking
as much responsibility as i had to
in those interactions i have to
you know
in my relationship with johnny and as
you have to and somebody will not and
cannot take any accountability for
anything they do in a fight as johnny
couldn't and wouldn't
um i took on as much as i could for
myself
um you know i had the whole relationship
been
blamed for everything for his drinking
for him hitting me for everything in
between blame for walking away blame for
staying i blame myself as well
blame myself for my part in it wait
blame myself for staying blame myself
for putting up with it and frankly
at a certain point
it's easier to take the blame feels
easier
it's
it almost feels better to take the blame
for something than to accept
the senseless nature of the violence you
can't change
you know there's almo it's almost more
reassuring to take accountability for it
than to
accept
the senseless nature of the violence
that you can't change no matter what you
do
no matter what i did
no matter what i did still hit me
i'm not going to take you to october 5
2015 and you're under plaintiff's
exhibit depths exhibit 393 a
another recording
2 colon forty two three colon forty
three
move the admission
no objection all right three ninety
three a plaintiffs and evidence
tony they don't know none of your
friends whether they saw a tiny fraction
that was the tip of an iceberg
a tip of an iceberg that was my reaction
to yet again
this happening
that is the tip of the iceberg if you
want to use that as some sort of like
mental
excuse or validation of of whatever of
telling your friends or whatever they
think or whatever they think about me or
whatever
fine
but they only saw a tip of an iceberg
none of your friends
have actually been there for one of our
fights they've never actually seen
really have they been in the hallway
yeah
baby that is absolutely not true they
have not heard everything maybe he could
[ __ ] quote us
great he can quote a part of it but he
has not been there no one has actually
been there
for a a fight in its entirety no how
could they no exactly so stop using that
it's some sort of excuse like this yeah
they know they work for you or they're
your friends then
please explain to the jury what you were
discussing in that
conversation
um
johnny would often use the fact that his
you know paid employees his loyal staff
would back him up in fights
and that they would he would constantly
threaten to call them in to validate him
they threatened to call them to come
into the room
to
have them back up
him and say that it was you know that my
yelling or that i'm at fault that i'm in
the wrong that it's all me and he would
do that in in
almost all of our fights especially at
2000 by 2015 that he would call his
friends and he'd call his staff and to
to back him up
so that i knew and would accept that i'm
at fault and that i met i'm wrong and
that was
you know what i had to agree to
over and over again just even hope that
we could have a conversation at some
point in a more therapeutic sense so we
could move the conversation
along um that that was his mo if you
will you can call people that work for
him to back him up
i'm going to take you to thanksgiving
2015. could you please just tell the
jury and we'll go through this one
relatively briefly but tell the jury
about thanksgiving and
any altercations you had with mr depp on
that occasion
thanksgiving 2015 we had friends
over
johnny had marilyn manson over and i had
a few of my friends over
we had a son over and
[Music]
maybe um
maybe my father i'm not entirely sure
how long he was there
we had dinner together um johnny uh was
disappearing with manson um doing coke
this objection calls her speculation
all right just seeing that objection how
do you know he was disappearing with mr
manson with coke um
that's what i knew of their relationship
at the time objections for speculation i
sustained the objection all right
so
he got up for a longer period of time
not the normal every five minutes to go
to the bathroom kind but like he just
appeared for a long period longer period
of time and at this stage i was
really um dependent on recognizing the
patterns of what he was i was reliant on
trying to figure out what he was on what
combination he was on so i knew how to
deal with him
it was incumbent
you know on me
because it affected my safety dealing
with somebody who is really high
dealing with johnny high on coke and and
speed meaning adderall or some version
of that is different from the opiate
johnny which is different from the booze
johnny or a different combination and
there was talk of quaaludes at the time
and johnny was trying to get it from
objection your honor
non-responsive that's sustained
objection if you want to ask so i was
continuing so i i wanted to know what i
was dealing with it was important to my
safety to know which objection
non-responsive
i think that's why i followed him to the
right your honor so what do you do
i'll sustain the objection next question
what did you do next i went upstairs
to the
apartment the main apartment not the
apartment that we were celebrating
thanksgiving in
to try to figure out what was going on
and
we had an argument
that took place downstairs and
i said something to provoke johnny i
went
up the stairs ahead of him
to get back to the party
he grabbed me at the top of the stairs
kind of through the stairs actually by
my shirt
kind of
flung me a little bit but i i just
remember i went into the bedroom kind of
retreated into the bedroom
i had a glass of wine in my hand at the
time which spilled
everywhere and shattered and i
kind of retreated into the bedroom
johnny came in after me
and there was this um heavy
like vintage style glass can
decanter
he picked up the decanter
and hurled it at my
head my face
it missed uh thankfully
um but smashed into a piece of art
behind me in the bedroom wall
uh above the bed
i um
[Music]
i got uh past him i think there might
have been
a bit of shoving i can't really recall
and the sequence of when that happened
but i went i wanted to go back
downstairs
and
i
passed my closet i had to change my
shirt
and um i went back downstairs to the
party to
finish the evening out and i put on a
you know a face and
we finished the evening with the guests
and then more fighting
happened after afterwards
so we talked about december 15 2015 last
thursday uh and also the bahamas
over the holidays um but i did miss one
picture and michelle can you bring up
defendants exhibit 518.
amber does that accurately depict the
scene portrayed
yes it does your i'd like to move the
admission of defendants exhibit 518. no
objection all right 518 defendants and
evidence you can publish and this is
from december 15 i believe could you
just please tell the jury what this
depicts
yes it's um
a picture of my bruce temple um
and johnny had his
hand on my uh on part of my face with my
face down
um
and um i was punching my head
i'm repeatedly punching my head
that's what caused that bruise in my
temple thank you
now we went through the bahamas before
and you returned from the bahamas
sometime
late december early january correct
yes okay
i'm going to take you to january
february of 2016. can you please
describe to the jury
what was going on with you and johnny in
this january time frame after this
december 15 and the bahamas incidents
after the bahamas
johnny sobriety
fell apart and there was just none of it
it was
uh so he stopped communicating with the
medical
team that he had hired objection culture
speculation
um how do you know that
uh i was there um they fired him
objections calls
um without telling what the medical
people did go ahead and tell what was
going on with you and johnny um
yeah his
uh his mental health for lack of what it
looked like his mental health was just
falling apart it's what it looked like
objection calls for speculation
i was sustained objection what did you
observe that led you to believe that his
mental health was falling apart
subjunction your honors culture
speculation you can just say would you
be observed i'll sustain the objection
as to leading next question what if
anything did you observe about mr depp's
uh state
he was hallucinating
auditory objection calls for speculation
he
sustained the objection please tell the
jury exactly what he was doing that led
you to believe he was hallucinating
objection leading sustained what if
anything was mr depp doing that would
have led you to believe he was
hallucinating
sustained what
please describe what mr depp was saying
in january of 2016.
he was talking to people who weren't
there
meaning people who were not in the room
he was communicating with people and
sounds and voices that weren't there i
know because i was sometimes in the room
and sometimes on the phone with him
and he would tell me i
had a conversation with him that i did
not have he would say i said something
that i didn't have he would comment on
somebody being in the room behind me
that wasn't there
it was terrifying
it was terrifying because you know once
he smashed a board right next to my face
and it was unclear to me whether he was
even mad at me or he was convinced that
the guy he said
he saw me with was in the room i didn't
know if he was in if johnny felt the man
was in the room with us or not at that
point
but i remember he put his fist through a
white a white board in the kitchen
he hallucinated
right in front of me and objection calls
for speculation don't use the word
hallucinate just describe what led you
to believe your honor
sustained the objection she can testify
to what she observed plea plea thank you
your honor please tell the jury what
your honor may we approach
but
tell the jury what you observed
um
i observed behavior from him that was
erratic irrational and didn't seem
connected to the reality that we're in
okay now i'm going to take you up to the
beginning of february of 2016 february
8th february 9.
please tell the jury what transpired
then with respect to mr depp
around this time
johnny was
again
behaving in a way it was very scary
it was terrifying um
and sometimes he didn't know
uh objection calls for speculation
i think she can describe what she's so
what are you are you describing what
you're observing yes please then please
continue
um
in these kind of discussions i would
have around this time early uh february
of 2016
sometimes in the argument he would
accuse me of something
some
person in the room with me that had just
walked out or i was hiding for instance
and sometimes he would hold on to that
even
when he seemed to have calmed down or
come off of whatever bender he was on
and
it was almost as if i had to confront
what he what delusion he had or what
belief he had or what accusation he made
of me
um
in a new fight altogether you know
sometimes he didn't
make it clear to me whether he was mad
at me or he knew he was mad at me it was
terrifying
because i bore the brunt of it and at
around the 8th or 9th i got
we were in his sweet sir compound the
west hollywood collection of homes that
he has
and uh i got some cryptic texts from him
in the early morning hours that scared
me i won't say
what i said but i i came over
to his
main house
i believe i'd been across the street and
i slept on the couch
we had some interaction in the morning
which made me fearful he didn't know
whether or not i was fearful he was
going to believe that he was angry at me
even though we weren't fighting i wasn't
fighting with him i had done nothing
wrong
but i was really worried
that
the momentum he was on was going to
click into a direction of
deciding that he was mad at me and i
deserved it and i was terrified that
that was going to happen so i was
i had an interaction with him and got
really worried about that on the morning
of the 10th all right
michelle i'm going to ask you to bring
up defendants exhibit 638 it's already
admitted in evidence your honor
this is from february 10 2016
and i'm going to ask you to play it
michelle
[Music]
ah
what happened
[Music]
nothing happened this morning you know
that
were you in here
no so nothing happened to you this
morning yeah you're right i just woke up
and you were so sweet
[Music]
we're not even fighting this morning all
i did was say sorry did something happen
to you
this morning
i don't think so
no that's the thing you want to see i'll
give you [ __ ] crazy
oh you're crazy
are you crazy have you drunk this whole
thing this
morning this guy
you got this going
oh really
really
shake that [ __ ]
didn't it you were smashing [ __ ]
why did you videotape this amber
because i knew he
wouldn't remember
objections or speculation sustained
rather than what you knew you can say
what you thought just tell us why you
i was afraid
scary that's scary
scared
scared they wouldn't remember
objection calls her speculation i
sustain the objection
all right
so i'm going to now take you
up to april 21
2016 your 30th birthday party
um will you please tell the jury what
happened that night with respect to in
particular mr deb
um he
uh
at that time we had a fitting that day
or the day before and he missed it and
he was kind of disappearing at that time
like at night
vaguely
saying like meetings he had meetings but
then he'd be gone for sometimes like two
days
i'm just not coming home and that sort
of thing coming home after a bender
calls for speculation
bender
i don't think that calls for speculation
i'll sustain the objection he's gone for
two days good
and
[Music]
i um had my my birthday was coming up
and i or on my birthday i said well you
know you're gonna
uh make it to my my birthday party we
had a dinner planned at our penthouse
i said it would be important for me if
you if you made it objection hearsay
not offered to prove the truth
thank you
and uh
he uh told me at some point that day
that he had scheduled a business meeting
or a money meeting i think he said maybe
uh seven
which is around the time my birthday was
planned for it might have been planned
for 8 pm
um
he
of course
once my party was starting he wasn't
there um text me at some point to let me
know that he was going to make it but
that he was
running late
and that continued throughout my party
we finished dinner
and um when we were cleaning up and kind
of everyone was stealing leaving because
we were waiting for
to give him an opportunity to show up
before it was before everyone left
um
and he
um
he let me he let me know he was there
um
you know i i tried to
without saying what i said i tried to
give him the impression that i wasn't
going to get on him about drinking or
anything i just wanted him to be there
and we had
a toast we did a celebratory toast
and the guests left
and
uh later that
evening um we were in bed and
um
i was i had a book and johnny um
effectively said what
which what's your [ __ ] problem now
and uh at the time we were getting
advice
from therapists without saying what they
said um
it was important for me not to
make him feel attacked
so i chose my words carefully i won't
say what i said but i
i remember being very careful about how
i worded what i was feeling
um about
my birthday and him having missed it
an argument um followed that
i
got up out of bed
johnny's side of the bed was closer to
the door than mine i remember blocking
the door blocking me to get out kind of
shoving me down and
we had a you know verbal argument
and then that became a shoving match i
tried to shove him back
um
i kind of felt myself retreat into the
into the bedroom at some point he um
picked up a
like a large i guess it's a magnum size
not a normal size a large size uh bottle
of champagne and hurled it at me
um
this time it went through a painting
and
i loved this painting i remember just
went like right through the canvas
left a giant hole in it
and um
i'm not thinking we shouldn't have art
in our bedroom anymore
um
and
the the fight the argument the fight
continued into the salon area which was
outside of our bedroom at the top of the
stairs
johnny picked up my phone i don't know
why
uh i don't remember what he was saying
when he did it but he picked up my phone
and threw it out of the open window of
the
salon area
out onto the street out onto the
downtown street that um this window
overlooked
uh
in that moment i
i went oh no you don't i saw his on the
countertop and picked it up and threw
his immediately like two seconds later
um i didn't want to be stranded uh this
time
alone meaning i didn't want to be the
only one stranded without a phone which
had happened to me already several times
before this
um from johnny so i picked up his phone
through it as well
um
and
i said that i wanted to go stay
somewhere else for the evening i left
that room went into the office
um
we were still
screaming names at each other and
screaming at each other
and uh i walk around the side of his
desk and
the next thing i know he has me by the
herring pulls me down kind of i hit the
side of the desk i remember things
flying off of the side of the desk that
that i hit with
with my body
um
i remember trying to
fight him off of me
at some point
we're back in my my main bedroom
and uh it's my i believe i was getting
my toothbrush out of that bathroom and
uh when i came out we had another
[Music]
shoving match but this one he kind of
like
i remember he chest bumped me
in this like bro way chest bumped me and
fell to the floor and when i got back up
he kind of
held me down by the shoulders down on
the side of the bed kind of
held me um
wrestled me down on the bed i remember i
got up once or twice before i ended up
on the bed and he grabbed me
um did this thing that he did sometimes
when he taught me grabbed me by the
um
the pubic
bone pubic
area just
as best i can describe it as he kind of
just
pushed me down held me down by it and
kind of pulled me into it and um was
asked he was asking me kind of taunting
me asking me if i if i thought i was so
[ __ ] tough i think you're such a
[ __ ] tough guy huh are you so tough
now look who's so tough you want to be a
man
tough like a man now
that
happened for
a bit of time i i'm not quite
sure um
i think at some point he left i remember
at some point shortly
after that i remember he was still in
the apartment when this happened but i
remember
kind of
collapsing on the floor and
being exhausted
it's just i remember feeling exhausted
and crying
and kind of throwing in the towel if you
if you will i remember
saying to him just can we not fight like
this
can we start over is there anything that
we can do
like this is
really messed up but can we just not do
this please
can we stop doing this just don't leave
it's my birthday let's just let's let's
just call it couch let's call it truce
and not have it end like this i don't
want to
have it in like this
i was just so tired
hurt and i remember crying and feeling
ridiculous
that after this i would be crying and
saying these things
i'm embarrassed saying it now
um
he responded uh
cruelly he told me it's what i [ __ ]
deserve and that i'd wake up every i'd
wake up alone
um and that no one would ever love me
because
all of this pointing to my
face or body all of this was gonna go
away no that ever loved me or my sag no
one ever loved me and i better get used
to waking up alone
um
and
he
said this is all my fault and what i do
what i asked for and he left i heard
him come back in
uh the downstairs you know you can hear
the door slam i remember hearing it open
and thinking
oh god is this going to happen again
what's going on now
um and
and then shortly after i kind of peeked
around to the top of the stairs where
you can kind of peer into the lower
level
and i uh i just see him briefly
momentarily and he just screams at me
happy [ __ ] birthday
and stormed out
at some point i walked downstairs and
saw that he had also
left me a note to that effect
how did he leave a note for you
i was written on a piece of paper as
best i can recall but i'm not sure
and
so then
the next day what did you do
um
i texted actually i took well i can't
say what i texted um i woke up this that
morning the morning of my 30th birthday
and
um i woke up to my best friend crawling
in bed with me
and putting her arms around me
and
[Music]
i remember wondering how she got
how she walked in
because there was a lot of glass on the
floor with lots of glass and um
she put her arms around me and showed me
a birthday video that all of my
friends my childhood friends all my
loved ones made
of course
stupidly the first thing i asked her is
why johnny wasn't in the video because
it had been recorded before it had been
recorded some time before it was clear
and she said um
that she'd been asking for a few months
and
john objection your honor hearsay and i
eventually we got out of my bed and
grabbed a few things and
got the bat got the dogs
left for for
our plans which our plans had been to go
to coachella which is a music festival
that happens in california
and that had been the plan for a while
that that's how we would go and
celebrate my birthday and i remember you
know um as i am accustomed to doing just
trying to
move through move on and
remember in vain trying to
put on a brave face and have a good time
even though it was impossible
let me stop you for a few things what if
any plans were there for mr depp to join
you at
coachella uh he
was
supposed to drive down have dinner um
stay
in the room maybe
do some writing or something like that
in the room
at
at coachella where we were coachella um
happens in a different part of
california than we lived in we lived in
los angeles and this happens about two
hours two to three hours away
um so
i finally got my car back
and um
and i drove with my um best friends in
in in the car and i'm gonna stop you
again because i just have a couple more
questions before we go into that part uh
you said you brought the dogs
who were the dogs you brought
johnny's dog
at the time boo
my dog pistol we shared them
their teacup yorkies and i believe
raquel my best friend's dog which is a
mud okay what if any issues did boo have
with uh
bathroom problems if you will objection
leading and relevance
overruled a lot
um
she had eaten uh johnny's weed when she
was a puppy
and had uh bowel control issues for her
entire life among some other issues she
was you know we regularly had to take
her to the vet to try to figure out
well what was wrong with this dog never
met a dog that
was quite like this
so she had some control issues
hence
why we would she liked to burrow in the
bed she liked to be in the you know by
the foot of the bed underneath the
covers and
it was um
customary that they slept in bed with us
but boo
having the issues she had we have to
leave her in bed so that she wouldn't be
encouraged to to go to the bathroom um
which would happen almost immediately
once you put her down on the floor and
sometimes it happened in bed too
but
um
but yeah
so what if anything did you notice
about any bathroom issues in your bed
before you left for coachella
well
raquel and i were both in in that bed um
with the dogs and i didn't notice
anything but we left them in the bed
while we packed a bag
to go to coachella you know so that
they didn't so that boo particularly
didn't lose control for about or you
know didn't go to the bathroom on the
floor so you'd leave them in bed until
you're ready to take them outside to the
patio which is
their designated bathroom break area
and what if any plans were there how
often did you have housekeeping keeping
at that time at your house
um the housekeepers were there every
morning
or they came every day as far as i know
okay
now
we'll get you to coachella but
why did you tell starling jenkins
that you had been involved in a prank
gone wrong objection hearsay leading i'm
said why your honor i didn't say what
she said i'll sustain the objection next
question okay um
did you commit any kind of prank
absolutely not
absolutely not and and
why
would
that not be something you would do
first of all i don't think that's funny
i don't know what
grown woman does
i was not also in a pranking mood i had
my life was
falling apart i was um
at a crossroads in my life that was
really
serious and i had just been attacked on
my 30th birthday
by my violent husband with whom i was
desperately in love
and knew i needed to leave
it was uh not really a jovial time
and i don't think that's funny period
that's disgusting
and what if any uh understanding did you
have
of mr depp coming back to your bedroom
that night or the next morning
objection culture speculation i i'm
asking what our understanding was i'll
sustain the objection okay did you
had you had any conversations with mr
depp about him coming back to the house
the next day
no johnny didn't come back to that house
that was my
that was my
you know he owned it but that was my
house when when we were having any sort
of problem in fact that was my house
just 90 of the time because he just
didn't
come back
that was not a place that johnny was
going to be in that johnny was in and he
had stormed out on my birthday and as
per
what we did it was he would go and stay
at his west hollywood home and i would
stay at the downtown places
he wasn't going to come back to the
objection calls for speculation
i think she explained her answer on that
one
just the last part okay thank you
all right so let's take you to coachella
um
who drove
i drove okay and who was in your vehicle
my sister
my friend savannah i believe
my best friend raquel
just my my girlfriends i i typically
surround myself with my girlfriends it's
my sport
was there any
occasion in which you were riding in the
vehicle that starling jenkins was
driving
he picked us up from coachella in the
evening when we as a group all
were ready to leave um that was
the um
the day that we went which was a um
which was the day that i took mbma and
mushrooms at the same time
realized very shortly after what a
horrible idea that was considering the
state that my life was in
i highly don't recommend that
combination at the time so i didn't feel
like being in a crowd
i didn't feel like being at coachella i
had intended to try to have a good time
despite what was going on in my personal
life and
i realized that
that was just not going to happen and so
i wanted to go home i wanted meaning to
be in a bed i wanted to be
you know i just wanted to be held by my
best friend and
watch a movie and that's what we did i
didn't feel well and wanted to leave
okay and
when you said you rode back with
starling jenkins was it just you or did
you have other people in the vehicle
with you and when we left coachella it
was my entire group i wasn't ever alone
with starling i certainly wasn't
anywhere near him i didn't have a
conversation with him i sat in the very
back seat with my best friend next to me
and it was a whole group of us
thank you um you ordered this
this might be a good breaking all right
that's fine okay ladies let's go ahead
and take our morning uh recess do not
discuss the cases with anybody and don't
do the outside research we'll take 15
minutes okay
so
all right
all right we'll just come back then at
10 50. is that okay all right 10 15.
thank you
all right we ready for the jury yes rob
okay
sure
okay
all right then
next question
what if any contact did you have with mr
depp during the period from april 21
to may 21 2016.
i had no physical contact with him okay
i'm going to take you to may
2
2016
the met gala
can you please just briefly describe to
the jury what a met gala is where it is
and what's involved
uh it's arguably the biggest
fashion
kind of celebrity event red carpet event
of the year it happens every year in new
york city
and were you invited i was invited um
typically designers uh will invite
people in the public eye to be their
um you know guest and they will
typically dress them and it's a way for
designers or fashion to kind of
intersect with the
a celebrity world and and it's a big
event held at the museum every year
and what if anything did you and mr depp
do to prepare for that met gala
well johnny and i were uh
we were
dressed by ralph lauren guests of ralph
lauren
uh and johnny missed the fitting uh
because it was happening around
the date of my birthday party in los
angeles
but we were planning on going
together
as ralph lauren's
guests
okay and did you show up
i did i didn't have a phone at the time
because
i couldn't get it reinstated
after johnny threw it out of the window
because no one on his
team would
would respond to me um so i had no way
to kind of reinstall it i had
um it's no point in getting a burner
phone if you don't know anyone's phone
number so i um
i i wasn't sure really what was going on
or when he would show up or if he would
show up
no one would talk to me on his team
no one would tell me i didn't know
so i ended up going um by myself
um
frankly i wasn't sure if you'd show up
and
you know on the carpet or if you'd show
up at the hotel shortly before
i had no way of knowing
and then did you attend the med gala
i did i um
i got out of the car and walked the red
carpet by myself
escorted by somebody from
ralph lauren's team um
and uh i sat next to an empty place
setting for johnny
um that they
they cleared as soon as we realized that
he wasn't
that he effectively stood me up on the
carpet
who did you meet at the met gala
i
was standing in line um right in front
of a gentleman
it was elon
i didn't recognize him
until we
started talking
and he had reminded me that we had met
once before he was with his mother
and did you strike up a friendship with
mr musk after that
we did we um as i mentioned we spoke on
the on the red carpet kind of on the
waiting
in the waiting line
of the carpet and
he seemed like a real gentleman he was
really nice and
he sat next to me well not next to me he
sat
kind of in a nearby table and we got to
speaking that night and then eventually
became friends
okay
i'm going to michelle can you pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 46 it's already in
evidence it's aaron fellotti's notes and
i'm going to ask you to go to page 30.
and i'm going to direct your attention
to the entry for 5 11 2016
where it says
uh
if i can see
here we go let me let me see if i can do
some reasonable
highlighting here
okay it says client laughed
and also reported using illicit drugs
mushrooms and mdma on 5 9 2016 at home
with a high profile male
acquaintance court
client reported that her husband was not
aware of the male visitor nor her
illicit drug use do you see that
yes i do who who was the
high-profile male acquaintance that
would visited your home on 5 9 2016.
uh i don't recall even being in la at
that time
where were you i don't recall
i believe i was in london at the time
okay um
did you have a male high profile client
at your home in or around 5 9 2016 uh
not around that date it seems like it's
a
wrong date okay and did you
use illicit drugs mushrooms and mdma
with any high-profile client
uh no i did that at the coachella music
festival and that was the end of that i
learned the hard way that that was a
terrible idea all right well while we
are on
the um
these same notes i'm going to say i'm
going to refer to the coachella which is
up above and it says it states she
ingested mushrooms and mdma
simultaneously while also consuming
alcohol and states she vomited and was
high for at least 24 hours straight were
you high for at least 24 hours straight
no i was not i i felt awful
but i was at home feeling awful
at home meaning at the hotel
with my best friend in bed
okay well while i'm still on these notes
let's go i know um while aaron fellati
was was uh testifying we recall
the 521 2016
isn't on here uh you'd sent her pictures
correct
yes i did then let's go to 526
2016. and it says client reports having
the hardest week of my life client
states she cannot deal with the negative
media publicity she has received
and then if we can jump that up michelle
to the next page surrounding the divorce
she requested from her husband jd do you
see that i do okay
when did you go in for the dv tro
may 27th so that was the day after aaron
fellotti's note saying you just had the
toughest week of your life that's
correct okay
while we are still on this one let's go
up to the first page
for the client history
when did you provide a client history to
aaron falady
never
when did you first get assigned aaron
fellotti
uh
i believe september of
2014. okay
now it says here that
client
reports a history of substance abuse
including an addiction to cocaine and
liquor
when did you have a substance a history
of substance abuse including addiction
to cocaine and liquor
i did not there's a lot of mistakes in
here okay did you ever use cocaine i
have i used cocaine a few times when i
was 18 19 years old
but stopped using
any
drugs including cocaine when i got into
a relationship with my ex-partner she
was very against that and
i'm glad for it
okay
then it also says here
that
uh
i'm gonna keep move up a little here we
go client admits to history of
anxiety eating disorder attention
deficit disorder bipolar disorder
co-dependence issues and occasional
insomnia
when have you had an eating disorder
i've never had an eating disorder
when have you been diagnosed with
bipolar disorder
i've never been diagnosed with bipolar
disorder
when have you been diagnosed with
codependence issues i have never been
diagnosed with codependency issues
although arguably at the time
from where i well at from where i stand
now i can see that the relationship i
was in with with johnny was certainly
codependent
but i wouldn't have reported that at the
time i didn't know about that all right
and then can we move up a little bit
more michelle
thank you
it has per report from jd debbie rn dr
kipper
client ah has reportedly been
experiencing increased anxiety and
agitation recently and has had several
outbursts of anger and rage were you
present for this being reported to ms
falotti
no this is the detox
okay this is johnny's
and it also says your mood has been
labile
what if any outbursts of anger and rage
and labile mood did you exhibit during
the detox
none that she would have seen none i i
was there for johnny's detox this is
what johnny was going through this is
not me okay and
at the time of the detox was aaron
fellati your nurse yet no i didn't know
her and she wasn't there okay
thank you very much you can take this
down michelle
now i'm going to take you to may 21
2016
and i'd like you to describe for the
jury what took place that evening in
connection with mr death
johnny and i had not seen each other for
the better part of a month or about a
month
i was traveling i just shot a campaign
in italy
i spoke to him
around that time when i was in italy
i had gotten a phone
my parents got a hold of me
after i spoke to my parents
i communicated with johnny
he
on that phone call um you know i didn't
know what was going on with him for
those weeks
with his sobriety i didn't know where
his state was i didn't know what state
he was in
and when i spoke to him
he um was saying what i can only just
he was going on about um
about scientists and dna and uh
feces
that he had
some some
you know scientific
analysis done and dna analysis done and
that you know
as soon as i heard about
this feces he thought um that was a
prank and
he was going on about all the
the scientists that he had conferred
with about the dna results with i just
thought he was out of his mind
and thought clearly the drinking and
the drugs are not getting better clearly
the delusions aren't better so
speculation
it's not
the truth of the matter we're talking
about what her i'll sustain the
objection next question please continue
so i um
i hung up from that phone call
assuming that and
then spoke to him
once once my my parents got a hold of me
to tell me about betty sue
we made a plan johnny and i for him to
come over he said he really needed his
wife
he had lost his mother and he missed his
wife he really needed his wife he said
it over and over again
i felt torn i felt conflicted i didn't
think
obviously the situation hadn't gotten
better with johnny mentally and i was
afraid that
all the work and progress and distance i
had finally got on it on the
relationship for the first time i had a
month of distance on it you know um i
didn't want that to be undone but i also
wanted to be
you know i was affected by the fact that
his mother
had passed so
uh he said he wanted to come over and
talk about that and he said he needed
his wife and
we made a plan um i
uh we made a plan for him to come over
during the day thinking that that might
mitigate the amount that he would be
drinking
night is a little bit more dangerous
and uh
in the early evening hours i get a text
from him that he's
almost there or that he's there i think
it was around 7 15 or so
and he
came over
and
[Music]
we sat on the couch and at first kind of
it was relatively peaceful i mean i
could tell he was
inebriated but makes sense in my head it
made sense
it wasn't he wasn't like incoherent it
was peaceful
and then he starts talking about the
feces again and this prank
that he said one of my friends had left
for him in my bed that he wasn't going
to be at
and i tried to point out how that didn't
make any sense i'm not even going to be
there i wasn't there
and my friends wouldn't do that that's
not something a bunch of 30 year old
women think is funny what is he talking
about and he just kept going on and on
about it
so
i uh i text my friend that it's
objection hearsay
don't don't tell us don't tell the jury
what you texted your friend but go to
the next thing what did you do next
i uh called
my friend thinking that it would um
quell this what i could only see is a
delusion i thought it was just a
delusion he was having and i thought oh
i'll
i'll
hopefully
you know quell this by calling
my friend to to if he hears my friend
say
that didn't happen
she's she's it's not out for the truth
please continue so i thought if i could
get my friend on the phone to to prove
that this didn't happen we could move on
and talk about
the issues
that we should be talking about you know
we had
our marriage was
over and falling apart in front of our
eyes we hadn't seen each other for a
month and his mom had just passed i
couldn't believe he wanted to talk about
feces
so
i call this friend thinking that we'll
take care of it the friend doesn't
answer
i call another friend who is
someone else he claimed i don't know how
both people did this but he was claiming
that this person was responsible so i
called that person
and that person is on speaker phone
and i say who that person is i o i o
tell it right i o tell it right okay
and then you put him on speaker phone
with johnny right in front of johnny
okay
and what happened next i
i allowed for an opportunity for io to
say why this is impossible objection
here it's not offered to prove the truth
of the matter is asserted your honor
it's explaining the context that leads
to the next
acts your honor
it is being offered
here we're not here about whether i know
i'll sustain the objection next question
all right um
all right so
io is talking you can't tell us what he
said okay objection
correct may we approach okay
so io is talking
we can't say what he said
what is the next thing that happens on
your end with mr depp
um
it just made johnny madder he got more
upset grabbed the phone
and started screaming at i o
uh
he
just started screaming at the top of his
lungs
said you died [ __ ] you don't know
you're talk you know just screaming
expletives insulting names
um and
telling io that
he can have me and you know [ __ ] off and
just screaming at him um
i i you know as best i can describe it
without getting into the details he
tosses the the phone you know down on
the couch
and heads upstairs
and i pick up the phone
and
and try to you know
apologize
for
the fact that my
husband at the time just screamed at my
friend on a cold call
i didn't want io to think that's why i
had called io you know to just be
screamed at and blamed for something
that sounded crazy for lack of a better
explanation it sounded crazy
io um
said something to me on speakerphone
um
and
reminded me i wasn't safe
objection honor hearsay you're honored
it's not offered to prove the truth of
the matter it's to show what caused mr
depp to be set off and come back i mean
it's not offered to prove the truth of
what he's saying
it's not hearsay i'll overrule objection
thank you please tell us what io said
and what then happened with mr deb
ayo said amber get out of the house get
out of the house now you're not safe
get out of that house
i had been there
after the cleanup or for the cleanup
after december 15 2015 incident and
objection
responses
all right i think she can provide the
context i'll sustain the objection next
question so please please continue
johnny hears this when he's on the
stairs he made it up one flight of
stairs
heard this turned around came bolting
down the stairs
grabbed the phone from my hand
and really
really started screaming this time led
into io
uh
called io
every imaginal every imaginable horrible
name that you can
say to a lgbt pro
cue by person for one and and any person
any human being ever i mean just
screamed
at io um
some really nasty stuff and he when he's
done he says you know you want to you
want to have you want to have my woman
now you want to have my [ __ ] you can
have you you take her you can have her
and he
with that picks up just pulls his arm
back with the phone and throws it at my
face
hit me
right in my it felt like my eye
i put my
head in my hands
and immediately
start crying
um i
said you hit me with the phone johnny
you hit me
and i'm sitting on the couch i didn't
even have time to
react you know i i didn't even have time
to put my hands up i was still
sitting cross-legged in my
socks
on the couch and i haven't seen him for
a month and last you know several times
now that i've seen him
he's hit me and i didn't even have time
to react to this
he comes over to me
um
as i'm crying
and
he does that taunting thing
to me he says oh yeah i hit you huh i
hit you yeah
and he just
feels like whacks me on top of my head
and just this heavy
ringed hand landed on top of my
my skull grabs me by the hair yanks me
up off the couch i'm struggling to stand
up
and i don't know if he was intending to
hit me in the face or if he was just
trying to grab my face but he was making
this
gesture around my face to try to hold to
expose my face to him and he was like
yeah let me see how bad i hurt you let
me see it let me see how bad i hurt you
this time what if i pull your hair back
what if i pull your hair back
and
he yanks my hair back i'm trying to
prevent
him from landing the blows to my face
and trying to prevent my face from being
exposed
and i just remember this mocking
taunt he was doing with me as he
is
yanking me around the room
and then i hear my friend come
into the room
i hear her
johnny hears her too
he lets go of me in turns and just tell
the jury who your friend is
raquel my
best friend at the time who lived in the
neighboring apartment
she
[Music]
came in
and uh johnny
moved towards towards her
and she ran towards me um johnny looked
at her looked at me
i retreated to the only place i had to
go which is the corner room the where
the couch was i retreated kind of to the
couch and
raquel
and johnny both ran up to me
uh john raquel got in front of johnny
she kind of
managed to get right in front of him in
between he and i
and
i'll never forget it just very
slowly
very very in just a very slow but very
concentrated very controlled slow way
just put both of her arms her hands up
like this and like i've seen people do
with horses that's what it reminded me
of she just went
no
no johnny no and she just got in front
of us in between us put her both of her
palms out
johnny kind of squared off to her ran
into her
arms and she just repeated herself very
slowly
very calmly very directly
he hit both of her arms off of his chest
like that
and barreled towards me
i instinctively
curl up on the couch
and i just feel her arms come around me
next to me she was sitting on my left
next to me on the couch i just feel her
arms around me
and i'm just looking down at the carpet
feeling her arms
and that's when johnny
who i can see
partially and here is right in front of
me and he's screaming at me to get the
[ __ ] up
amber get the [ __ ] up
amber get the [ __ ] up amber get the [ __ ]
up and every single time he said it
you screaming it louder and louder and
louder
i think he screamed it probably about 10
times
so loudly
the next thing i hear is boss boss and i
realized that his two security guards
had come into the
to the apartment after raquel
i see them and
or hear them and
johnny turns to them and i i see jerry
say boss boss
and i get up off the couch and i say to
jerry objection your honor here say i'm
not offered to prove the truth of the
matter asserted at all i'll sustain the
objections all right next one so don't
tell us what you said to jerry just what
happened next
then they
tell him
something
um
and
he
picks up the the bottle
that i guess he walked in with uh was uh
mr depp or jerry i'm sorry johnny okay
and uh
starts smashing things off the
nightstand the
the coffee table
starts screaming
and they kind of
i feel them kind of corral him i'm not
making direct eye contact but i can kind
of just sense and feel and sound and
hear
things smashing
as he exits the
apartment kind of knocking things off
the countertops and
uh breaking things on the way and i
um realized he you know he's punching
something i
assume it was the picture because it
it broke right after he walked past it
and he leaves that apartment i hear him
in the hallway
still screaming i hear more doors
opening more racket
eventually josh raquel's
a husband
comes into the room and
uh
brings me to safety brings for kel and i
to safety in
um in their apartment
and that's where i stayed for
the next few hours so who called the
police
i i believe it was obviously speculation
your honor this is you we have to have
the context here of somebody called the
police because then the police come so i
think we have to put i mean it's not
offered again to prove the truth of the
matter asserted it's just who called the
police your honor the objection is not
hearsay it's speculation do you know who
called the police yes i do now
i'll sustain the objection
did you have a conver did you were you
present when there was a discussion
about calling 9-1-1 objection calls for
hearsay i'm asking if she was president
sustained objection next question
did you call 9-1-1 no
okay did rocky call 9-1-1 objection
calls for speculation do you know
whether rocky called 9-1-1
i do know whether she did
and did she did not okay
um
all right so
what happens when did you learn
that the police had been called
roughly
an hour
i don't
at some point shortly after
uh johnny and his security guards left
and what did you do as a result of
knowing that the police were coming
i
i felt panicked i
i didn't know what to do
because
i didn't know what they were going to do
when they saw
the state of the place he'd also smashed
up the other apartment where i kept all
my things so i didn't know what they
were going to do and i panicked i called
i called the only lawyer i have which is
my
entertainment lawyer he does like my
movie contracts and stuff
and i
asked him for advice
and then
without telling what he said
what happened next
i called a domestic relations attorney
after that conversation and had you
known this domestic relations attorney
before then no i did not did you get
that name from your entertainment
attorney yes i did okay and when you
called the domestic relations attorney
without saying what she said
what did you do as a result
i
told the police officers who arrived
that i would not objection your honor
hearsay again not offered to prove the
truth of the matter asserted all right
i'll overall objection thank you
i'm sorry could you repeat that
i repeated to the officers i refused to
cooperate at this time at the advice of
my attorney
okay
did you
call your publicist that night
no okay
um
now i'm going to ask you to take a look
at
some pictures
but before i get there i want to just
ask you a couple of questions leading up
what were you doing when the police
officers arrived
when
at that time when i
after i learned that they were coming
uh
my best friend
took pictures of me
uh we took pictures of the house and my
face
okay
i'm going to and
did your best friend take any pictures
while the officers were there
we took pictures before
and while they were there and after okay
we took pictures throughout okay
so i'm going to take you now michelle
can you bring up defendants exhibit 706.
i think we can do the native on this one
yes thank you
uh does this accurately depict the scene
portrayed
yes it does your honor i'd like to move
the admission of defendant 706
no objection 706 in evidence
and would you please describe to the
jury what this is a picture of
this is
my face after johnny threw a phone edit
okay
i'm going to now michelle asked you to
pull up defendants
708
and does this accurately depict the
scene portrayed in this picture
yes it does all right and i also see
that there is a a a little what we call
metadata item on there how
how do you get that on a picture how
does that happen can you just describe
briefly objection your honor that's
speculation lack of foundation
can you please explain how this
particular
item on here got onto the pictures
it's a
it's a feature that was on um
iphotos you know where the
where your pictures are stored on your
phone typically you just push
info
and and was that pushed in this these
instances i pushed info and that's what
came up okay you're right i'm gonna move
the admission of defendants in 708. the
objection of seven your honor i would
just ask the picture be redacted um on
hearsay grounds um
your honor for the metadata
okay
you're one moment please i'm trying to
figure out how to move this fast okay
that's fine
okay
all right i'm going to move the
admission of 708 with the redaction url
okay and the objection to that um there
still needs to be another reduction at
the top your honor okay
we'll get it
okay thank you
okay 708 with the redactions okay thank
you your honor and i would also like the
record to reflect that are we um
we're publishing this to the jury yes no
objection correct okay okay yes
there you go
okay i would like the record to reflect
that this was the photo that was shown
to officer signs and officer hadn't
objection
that that is you're on a
because we weekend
identified him now the jury should be
entitled to know which photos that we
approach okay
so for the record this particular photo
was shown to officer signs and officer
hadden as exhibit 24 in both of the
depositions that were shown earlier
where the pictures were not uh allowed
to be shown yet because they hadn't been
admitted amber will you please describe
for the jury what what is depicted in
this
photo
yes that's a picture of my face um taken
um
that evening um shortly before 9 30
um after johnny hit me with the phone
okay
now we can take this one down and let's
go to defendants exhibit 709
and based on the court's ruling i'm
going to ask if you can redact that
michelle please
remove the admission of 709.
any objection not with rejections thank
you 709 with redactions and evidence you
can publish
if it could be published to the jury
honor thank you and your honor for the
record this is the photo that was shown
to officer signs and to officer hadden
as exhibit 25 for both of their
depositions
okay amber could you please describe for
the jury what's depicted here
uh that is my face
after
um after the phone incident
that's that night
all right let's uh bring
defendant 710 please
and you're going to move the admission
of exhibit 710 the redactions have been
already placed on it any objection
no objection thank you 710 with
redactions you can publish if we can
publish your
honor and for the record this a photo
was shown to officer signs and officer
hadden it was exhibit 26 for both of
their depositions
and please describe for the jury what's
depicted here amber
that is my face and
uh yet a different
light um that same evening
after johnny hit me with the phone
okay
let's go ahead and go to defendants
exhibit 7-eleven
[Music]
and i'm going to move the admission of
7-eleven your honor with the redactions
all right any objection no objection all
right 7-eleven with the actions and
evidence publish
and for the record your honor uh for the
jury's purposes this was shown to
officer signs and officer hadden is
exhibit 27 to both of their depositions
and could you describe what's depicted
here amber
yes that is another angle another
lighting of my face
uh after the phone
okay
and when you say angler lighting what
did rocky do in taking these pictures
junction calls for speculation
i said what'd she do
thank you
uh
raquel um
took pictures of my face in various
um places around the penthouse and the
apartments have really different
lighting you know really dark in some
places
anyway so we just took pictures in
different lighting so that um
we had an accurate
portrayal and depiction of what had
happened
and why did you take the pictures
uh raquel did it to protect me because
the cops were coming and um we knew we
or that we knew that the police
i think at this point that we they were
already here they were with us but we
weren't
maybe this was right before i'm not
quite sure without seeing the time stamp
but
we weren't sure what was gonna happen
what the police were gonna say what they
were gonna do
um
we didn't know what johnny was going to
do what he was going to
say so she wanted to protect me okay
so
let's go ahead and bring up 712.
all right now move the admission of 712
your honor all right any objection no
thank you your honor 712 with redactions
you can publish
thank your honor
and please describe
what's depicted here
uh
that is a
another picture of my face
okay uh taken around the same time
okay and then let's go to 7 13.
move the admission of 713 your honor any
objection
no objection all right 713 with
redactions being published
and for the record this one was shown to
officer signs and officer hadden as well
as exhibit 29 to both of their
depositions
and just describe briefly to the jury
what this is this is a another picture
of my face taken at the exact same time
and in the same location as the other
one just with one of the lights turned
on
or an additional light turned on in the
previous one okay
let's go to 714.
move the admission of 714 your honor
no objection all right 714 with
redactions
and
please tell the jury what this depicts
is um another
angle of my face or another picture of
my face taken at a different time
i don't know if this is um
later before because i can't see the
time on it
okay
you take that down let's go to 7 15.
[Music]
i'm going to move the admission of 715
your honor
uh no objection all right said 15 with
redactions in evidence
thank you and uh for the record this one
was shown to officer signs and officer
hadden is exhibit 17 for both
please describe for the jury what's this
what's depicted here
that is a picture of my face
some point later on in the night it
looks like that was taken in
rocky's apartment or in the apartment
that she was staying in okay
and let's go to 7 16.
remove the admission of 7 16.
no objection your honor all right
7 16 evidence says redacted
and amber could you please tell the jury
what this picture depicts
uh yes it's the business card that one
of the police officers left for me
in case i changed my mind and wanted to
comment
and
with the pictures that we have just seen
before this were they taken before
the pictures of the
uh police
card the card that was left after or
do you know
compound it's nice and calls for
speculation
thank you
we took pictures before
during and after okay
and the question i had for you is the
pictures you've seen so far were those
taken before
at the time of this before this card was
presented to you and you took the
picture after or do you know
some of them were but without seeing all
the time stamps i can't tell exactly
okay that's fair thank you
okay and then i'm going to ask you to
take this one down and go to 7 17.
and i'm going to ask you
i'm going to move the admission of 717
your honor any objection no objection
717 is redacted and evident
thank you
and please just briefly describe to the
jury what this is
uh the two officers that um
first responded left me that card this
is the front of the business card they
left
can you
tell the jury just explain what the
interaction was that you had with the
police officers
just describing what you observed
as they came through
i did not want to speak to them i
asked that
raquel's
partner or husband
asked them to go away without speaking
to me and and just so the jury
understands who was judged who was
raquel's fiance at that time um
his name is josh drew and he and raquel
lived in the apartment at johnny's
invitation across the hall from us
um
raquel had keys we kind of shared keys
it was
they were our neighbors but
had keys to our house okay
so why didn't you want to cooperate with
the police
because i i
i wanted to protect johnny i didn't want
him to be arrested
i didn't want him to be in trouble i
didn't want the world to know
i didn't want this to come out
i didn't want him to be in trouble
i didn't want this to be
i wanted to protect johnny
let's go to
defendants exhibit 1374.
that's 13.74
one moment here all right
thank you
all right move the admission of 1374 a
your honor any objection
no objection 1374 to evidence 1374a in
evidence i'm sorry thank you um and
amber what is this
it's another picture of my face
uh after
johnny threw the phone at it okay
and then let's go to 1493t
ah
and move the admission of
1493 t
no objection all right 1493 t in
evidence
and what does this depict
um this is a picture of
um my eye my face
after that incident perhaps
by the lighting it looks like it might
have been taken the next day but i can't
tell i mean i can't tell for sure okay
and then let's go to 1493 s
and
move the admission of 1493 s
no objection all right 1493 s in
evidence
and what does this depict
uh and this is another picture of my eye
and
side of my face
now
were there also pictures taken of the
property that you described mr deb uh
destroying or damaging
yes there were okay michelle can you
bring up defendants exhibit 700
and
based on your honors rulings we will
take off the metadata
move the admission of defendants exhibit
700.
no objection with reduction 700 with
redactions you can publish
can you please describe to the jury
what's depicted in this photo
yes um my friend had was preparing for a
bead show and had displays to
show these bead necklaces she made
and she needed some counter space in
order to kind of set up the displays
that she was going to use the next day
so she asked me earlier in the day if
she could use the free counter space in
that penthouse penthouse five
to kind of set up those
those display racks they were set up um
in that room
um when johnny went in there to
destroy things as he does
uh and this depicts some of that damage
yeah he
security let him in even though i had
absolutely speculation
uh i i don't think that was speculation
lack of foundation
oh you're also seen as a foundation if
you want to okay um
so
what what does what's depicted what's
the damage that was done
well because
johnny would always smash up my things
and destroy my property when he was mad
at me um i
had
asked that they not let him in to so
that he could do that i mean the only
purpose to let for him to be led into
penthouse five in that state he doesn't
have property in there the only way for
the only reason for him to go in there
would be to destroy it and they of
course let him into penthouse five
objections that he could go
lack of foundation
all right i'll sustain the objection
next question just tell the jury what he
did here that's depicted in this this is
just a
one
corner of the room that shows the
destruction he just went in there with
this bottle swinging and destroy smash
bunch of things objection your honor
this is speculation she hasn't
established that she was there
i'll sustain if you want to lay a
foundation
okay
did anybody else to your knowledge go in
there and do this objection your honor
calls for speculation trying to lay the
foundation here we are i'll sustain the
objection next question let's do this
never mind we'll let somebody else tell
who did it okay sure um just all i'm
asking here is what what is the damage
what has been done that's depicted here
this is just one of raquel's bead rocks
that he um
absolutely on our speculation i'll
sustain all right let's go to 701
move the admission of 701
uh with reduction no objection
701 with redactions and evidence
thank you
amber can you please describe what's
depicted here
um yeah it is our
bedroom and penthouse
three the main penthouse um
looks like he was just
um
throwing things objection you're on our
calls for speculation
so
just describe what you see here as
opposed to what you say he did okay i
see a bunch of art um
tossed on the bed
okay where was that art before mr depp
was at your house on may 21
2016. um
hanging on the wall where it belongs
okay
let's go to michelle can you bring up
defendant 702 please
[Music]
oh you're honored i forgot on the last
two for defendants exhibit 700 that was
shown to officer signs in haddon it was
exhibit 39 to both of theirs and exhibit
701
was shown to hadn't only and that was
exhibit 30 in his deposition
i moved the admission of 702 please
any objection
no objection all right 702 with
redactions
thank your honor
and let the record reflect this was also
shown to officer hadden as deposition
exhibit number 40.
and can you please describe for the jury
what's depicted here
uh yes it has broken glass from one of
the broke broken um
pictures that were hanging on the wall
and where is this physically this is in
penthouse five on the stairwell okay
let's michelle can you bring up
defendant 703 please
move the admission of defendant 703
no objection all right 703 with
redactions you can publish thank you
your honor and the record let the record
reflect that this was shown to officer
signs and officer hadden as exhibit 41
for both of their depositions
and amber please describe for the jury
what's depicted here
uh it's another
photograph of this stairwell
uh in the same apartment penthouse five
and which is the apartment where i kept
my things okay
and is that glass on the stairway yes
from one of the broken
picture frames on the wall we had a lot
of picture i had a lot of picture frames
on the
on the walls
and
[Music]
many if not
most of them were smashed
okay
let's take this one down and go to 704
please defendants
michelle thank you
move the admission of defendant 704
no objection all right 704 with
redactions publish
thank you and let the record reflect
that this was shown to both officer
signs and hadn't as exhibit 34 to both
their depositions
and amber please describe for the jury
what's depicted here
uh just another
piece of glass it looks like the base of
a wine glass
that is in penthouse 3 the main
apartment
and when you say wine glass did you see
this particular
glass there were glasses
in the kitchen
and
always and when johnny was walking out i
saw him myself
swinging the magnum size bottle
and i could hear glass breaking
and
things falling okay
thank you michelle can you bring up 705
please
move the admission of 705
no reduction excuse me no objection all
right
705 in evidence thank you
go ahead
and let the record reflect this was
shown to officer hadden and exhibit 36
of his deposition amber can you please
describe the jury what's portrayed here
uh things knocked over on the kitchen uh
countertop and i see pieces of broken
glass on the countertop as well
let's go to 707
move the admission of 707
any objection
no objection you're all right 707 with
redactions and evidence thank you and
let the record show show that both
officer signs and officer hadden were
shown this picture it was exhibit 18 in
both their depositions amber could you
please describe to the jury what's
depicted here
this is the hallway leading
out
leading up to the apartments
so this is the hallway that connects all
of the apartments it's kind of an indoor
outdoor
sort of hallway meaning it's covered but
it's
it's exposed on the far ends of both um
to the elements so this is not carpet
it's like a uh
it's like a plasticky uh
i don't know how to describe the
material it's like a plasticy kind of um
netting not netting
it's difficult to describe but it's a
kind of an outdoor sort of carpet
all right and what's depicted there
uh wine on the floor and a little on the
wall it seems
okay
let's go to 7 18 please
oh the admission of 718.
no objection all right 718 with
productions and evidence
and let the record reflect this was
shown to officer signs and officer
hadden in deposition exhibit 31 for both
of them ever please describe for the
jury what's depicted here it's um
another
another photograph on the floor not the
wall
this one appears to be
remarkably unbroken
okay let's go to 719 please
with the admission of defendant 719
uh no objection all right 719 with
redactions thank you thank you your
honor and the let the record reflect
that this was shown to officer signs and
hadn't in their depositions exhibit 35
to both
and amber please just describe for the
jury what's depicted here
it's one corner of the
kitchen in penthouse 3. it looks like
one of the
one of the things that was knocked off
of the kitchen island when johnny left
okay
let's go to
defendant 720 please
thank you michelle
move the admission of defendant 720
no objection right 720 with redactions
and that the record reflector under this
was shown to officer signs and hadn't
deposition exhibit 43 to both
amber could you please describe to the
jury what's depicted here
that's um
my
office it's a corner of my office
and that is
a box of like
sentimental things things from my
childhood or things that are important
to me keepsake box that
has been dumped
out it looks like
okay
let's go to let's go to defendant 721
move the admission of defendant 721
no objection your honor 721 with
redactions published thank you your
honor and let the record reflect this
was shown to officer signs and hadn't in
deposition exhibit 44 for both
amber please describe for the jury what
this depicts
again my office
same thing different angle okay let's go
to 722
move the admission of defendants exhibit
722
no objection your honor 722 with
redactions and evidence thank you and
let the record reflect this was shown to
officer signs and officer hadden as
deposition exhibit 42 to both amber
please describe to the jury what's
depicted here
that's a picture of my friends and i um
when we were at that london house
um
that johnny punched
okay you saw him punch this i heard it
okay
all right let's go to 723 please
move the admission of defendant 723
any objection no objection all right 723
redacted in evidence let the record
reflect this was shown to officer signs
and hadn't in their depositions exhibit
38 for both
amber please describe for the jury
what's reflected um one of them
looks like a magnum bottle of wine
that is
empty or spilled on the floor
can you tell where that is located
um
looks like it would be penthouse five
okay
let's go to 724
move the admission of defendant 724
no objection all right 724 with
redactions thank you let the record
reflect this was shown to officer signs
in haddon as their deposition exhibits
33
amber please tell the jury what's
depicted here this is um more wine that
johnny was spelling as he was using the
um using the bottle he was holding as a
you know a bat of sorts
let's go to 725
we're almost done just two more
promise
move the admission of defendant 725 no
objection 725 for redaction the record
reflect this was shown to officer signs
in haddon and as deposition exhibit 37
to their depositions
amber please tell the jury what's
depicted here
uh more spilled wine on the floor this
looks like uh penthouse five
okay
and last but not least michelle please
defendants 726
[Music]
uh move the admission
um
no objection okay um
the jury
needs the tissue oh okay thank you
we hope we will get a tissue
you got some thank you
all right no objection 726 with
redactions thank you
all right and let the record reflect
that this one was shown to officer heinz
and hadden as deposition 32 exhibit to
their depositions and ever please just
describe to the jury what's depicted
here
more spilled wine on the floor
penthouse three appears
okay thank you
now
when the police officers were there
did either of them take you aside by
yourself and talk with you
yes
which one or both
uh the
mail officer i did not have much
interaction with the female officer
asked to
said she needed to speak to me by by
myself pulled me aside
uh we went into
penthouse three the main penthouse
uh to speak there because i had been in
penthouse one raquel and josh's
apartment
up until that moment okay and then what
if anything did she ask you
she asked me if i would make a statement
if i would
cooperate
she kind of indicated to me i don't
remember if it was a
what word she said but she kind of
gestured
to my face and
objection your honor hearsay
i think she could if she just
gesturing to her face is not here so
i'll assist the statement i'll sustain
the objection next okay and it's also
not offered to prove the truth i'll say
okay
so what happened next
i
uh
[Music]
let's do this how long were you with the
officer
when she took you aside
a few minutes
if that
okay
and as a result of that did you
cooperate
no i did not but
it was my understanding that
i couldn't stop them from walking
through the apartment which is what they
indicated to me
okay and were you with them when they
walked through the apartment uh no josh
well in i was with them at the beginning
of penthouse three
josh uh raquel's partner um took over
from there and showed them around the
house
up
through penthouse three which connects
on the top floor to the neighboring
apartment penthouse four and then on to
penthouse five they all connect on the
top level
so josh walked
the officers through the
to the house okay
and
what if anything
did you say about the identity of mr deb
nothing
were you asked
yes but you refused to tell them
objection leading sustain okay
why did you refuse to tell
the police officers mr depp's identity
because i did not
want them to arrest johnny
i did not want this to happen i did not
want
any of this to happen
i didn't want to get him in trouble
[Music]
so i said well i can't i i just refuse
to cooperate
okay
now after how approximately how long
were the police officers there
i don't recall exactly maybe
um
actually less than half an hour
i really don't know exactly but they
weren't there very long at all okay
now after the police officers left what
did you do
we cleaned up a bit uh
because there was broken glass and we
had dogs
so we tried to clean up the
mess and
especially the glass and um
josh rocky liz and i we kind of just
cleaned up and eventually
sat on the couch and they just tried to
comfort me
what if any knowledge did you have that
there was going to be a second set of
officers coming later that night
i didn't know about that that surprised
me
when did you learn that a second set of
officers were coming to the
penthouse that night i think i learned
about it when they were there when they
arrived okay
uh and
we've seen the the body worn video um on
that is there anything that you recall
outside of what was reflected on officer
gate and gaitlan's
video
i couldn't see much of
of what was on that video i just
uh i remember
being surprised that they were there not
really knowing why they were there i
assumed it was because i was encouraged
to make a statement by the first set of
officers
say
all right keep going forward okay and i
was sitting on the couch it was some
time hours maybe
maybe
maybe between an hour
two hours maybe more i don't really
recall but we had cleaned up and we were
resting and they were comforting me when
they came and
they didn't seem
to
they didn't do it the first set of
officers did they um just kind of came
into the apartment
confirmed that
we that that i was okay or that we were
okay they didn't really seem to
be that concerned
and they didn't demand to do a walk
through like the first set of officers
had
and they left
okay and what if any cooperation did you
give them
well
i didn't
need to i didn't really cooperate with
them i didn't talk to them i did i don't
i didn't even get up off the couch i was
speaking to them from
quite a bit of a distance like between
you and i and
maybe more and i didn't really say
anything i just kind of
acknowledged that they entered and that
i that
that was it
did you provide them with mr depp's name
no way
did they ask no
okay
all right
i'm going to take you to the next day
may 22
um
and i'm going to michelle can you bring
up defendants exhibit 772
what if any efforts did mr depp make to
reach out to you the day after this
happened
well he
he made
several efforts immediately he kind of
reached out and lashed out
um again
kind of going on what seems to be
slightly delusional thinking that just
because he saw all my friends beads out
on the countertop that it had become a
workshop or a studio for her so he
seemed angry about
you know this perception that this
bead display that my friend had set up
was evidence of her running some sort of
workshop and he also
accused us of having or me of having
invited someone else to live there who
who wasn't living there um who was just
in the apartment when johnny stormed in
so he just kind of lashed out and then
the tone changed and the days that
followed and let me stop you there so
i'm going to ask you to take a look at
defendants exhibit
772
uh and is this a text message from mr
depp to you
yes it is and it's on 5 22 at 12 23 a.m
so it's early morning hours after 5 21
would that be fair
yes your honor i'm going to move the
admission of defendant 772
no objection all right 772 in evidence
with the identifiers redacted
and published thank you
thank you your honor
all right and uh i know you started to
talk about this amber
um
but it says
uh
i'm an idiot ph5 is rocky's studio you
are shameless you see that yes okay was
that what you were talking about with
him thinking
that you're
yes okay
and then
uh
obviously we can read that he says i
tried to make it work you just turned
more and more into a spoiled brat all
you wanted was to make me [ __ ]
miserable while i'm finally there
i'll never be able to understand how i
fell in love with you you're not her i
loved you more than anything i did
everything that i could but you never
[ __ ] loved me i was merely convenient
for you i hope our divorce goes as
quickly as possible and that it is as
painless as possible so sorry you were
as unhappy with me
as you were obviously the purity of
whatever was has been gone for a long
time i will miss the moments of beauty
and truth goodbye amber what the [ __ ]
was i thinking i wish you all merit i'll
you merit the former hymn
um what if any discussions did you have
with mr depp about divorce that night
uh we did not
uh have a discussion about that uh that
evening we didn't have time he was
obsessed with
dog poop
okay that's what he wanted to talk about
all right let's take this down and let's
go to defendants exhibit 773
now this is a text exchange between you
and mr depp
it starts with mr depp on 5 21
at 6 58 pm just saying here does that
refresh your recollection of when he
arrived at your
penthouse on may 21
yes okay
and then the next series are on 5 22
they start at 5 13.
and
you're discussing talking you said sorry
i'm just leaving amanda's birthday now
do you see that
yes i do all right and then he responds
to that correct
yes all right your honor i'd like to
move the admission of defendant 773
your honor if we could just have a
minute to review this exhibit yes ma'am
is it just this page
uh no there's
three pages three pages i'm just reading
michelle's hands
so
no objection your honor all right 773 in
evidence with identifiers for decades
thank you
if we could
okay we've got it published to the jury
so let's go to the top michelle and so
it starts out with
with him this is the 5 21 6 58 p.m
saying he's there correct
yeah but i think he came in
later than that took him some time okay
and then if we move up the next one is
you
at
5 22
at 5 13 pm correct
yes and then you say thank you and then
can we still speak in min
what do you recall of why you sent those
texts
i believe we had spoken on the phone
or they
i can't uh control this correct the
screen i don't know we can give you
control yes maybe we should do that and
clear out my purples
i just don't know what was sent right
before that go ahead go ahead you're
gonna come she can't scroll she's asking
to scroll okay michelle let's have you
scroll if you can
just just go ahead and scroll through
just slowly
so she can read the whole thing
i
okay
um
all right does that help refresh your
recollection
uh yes i believe that
uh that
i believe he had
apologized to me after the phone
incident
i had commitments that i had to
attend the following day
on the 22nd so
the beach i referenced i mentioned to
you i had to go to i would also had to
bring a cake to a friend's birthday
party so i had things i was i
unfortunately had to do that day
and i remember there was communication
with johnny
both by phone and by text
where he was
telling me that he was clean
that he was sober he um was
clear mind it wasn't the monster
and that he was so sorry
um but
i
[Music]
i had already
committed to
filing for divorce
and
eventually
i have to
um let him know that it's not just
not just saying it in the anger in the
fights that like we had done you know
both he and i did that
uh at times in some of our fights
especially towards the end of our
relationship and so
uh
i let him know that i i was
i was um serious about filing this time
and that i had had enough after the
after the session you're on your hearsay
enough
okay overworld go ahead
all right i'm going to draw your
attention to the bottom of the page
defendants exhibit 773
and this is at 522 so this is 619 p.m do
you see that 5 22
and he says just let me know when you
have a minute and i'll give you a call
nothing i have to say
you should elicit anything but a sense
of ease do you see that yes and then he
says all my love and profound apologies
what was he apologizing for objection
calls for speculation
what was your understanding of what he
was apologizing for
speculation
objection
in his phone call with you did he tell
you what he was apologizing for
yes what did he say
he was sorry that
he reacted the way he did he said he
didn't mean to
hurt me didn't mean
to hurt me if he really hurt me that bad
he's sorry
that he just he didn't mean to
[Music]
okay michelle if we can go to the next
page
[Music]
up to the green please
and he says here
i'm sad i'm scared and i'm broken my
sweet slim
and then he says i want you happy i have
zero harsh feelings i am clear and i am
me
what did you understand him to mean by i
am clear and i am me objection your
honor calls for speculation do you do
you i know what he meant okay but your
honor is that phrase with you i'll i'll
hold on i'll sustain that objection
then you can ask your next question
thank you do you did he use those
phrases with you during your marriage
yes he did what did mr depp mean when he
says i'm clear and i am me objection
calls for speculation i think i
established the foundation
thank you
that he had sobered up
that he'd sobered up and he was not the
monster again that he was him
that he was a good guy i loved
the one that i trusted
all right now i'm going to ask michelle
if you can take that one down and bring
in 771 which has already been admitted
now those text exchanges were
did the six o'clock to almost seven
o'clock range
and here it's 5 22 it's now 8 o'clock
correct
yes
and he's telling you sorry if a bit
please know that my hurt towards you is
over
my apologies are eternal and belong to
you solid do you see that
yes okay
uh and
was it your understanding he was
apologizing again objection your honor
calls for speculation all right i'll
sustain the objection okay
was there anything else he would have
been apologizing for that he had done
objection calls for speculation
sustained objection
that's it okay
so
tell the jury how you felt in that week
may 22 through may 27 and what you
decided to do
at the time it felt like the hardest
thing i've ever had to do
i had worked so hard
to try to make this relationship work
i went to therapy and went to al-anon i
got help i read books i did everything i
could possibly do and it didn't work
and um
i finally was i was conflicted to answer
your question i was conflicted i
knew after he threw the phone at my face
that after all that that month of not
seeing each other
not getting better not getting clean and
sober there wasn't even
i didn't you know the the
the
oh it was falling apart i knew i had i
knew i had to leave him i knew i i
wouldn't
i knew i wouldn't survive it if i didn't
so
i made the decision to
to file for divorce
it was hard because um
you know i loved johnny so much
i loved him so much
and why did you file for divorce
because i knew if i didn't
that i knew if i did not likely not
literally survive
i'm britain
i'm so scared that it was gonna end
really badly
for me
and i am
i really didn't want to leave him
i loved him
so much
i wouldn't have done anything but i
couldn't
i couldn't do that one thing i couldn't
stay
the
the promise and the hope that i had i
had become less and less regular and
more and more rare the monster had been
this thing that was now the normal and
not the exception
the violence was now normal and not the
exception
it was um so
so hard
it was so hard but i knew i had to do it
[Music]
i believe he would have
taken it too far
i wouldn't be here
why did you ask for a domestic violence
temporary restraining order
i wanted to change my locks
i wanted to change my locks
i wanted a good night's sleep
security
would always let him into the house no
matter what i asked them no matter when
i when i begged them to let me know when
he was coming over no matter how much i
beg them not to let him in when he was
mad or drunk or high
and i just i couldn't sleep i wake up in
a panic
i was losing hair
i was losing weight
i got really sick
i had shingles i couldn't sleep i'd wake
up in a panic attack
i had panic attacks all the time
i was falling apart
i
was scared
and
very conflicted because
the person i was scared of is also the
person i was in love with
really really tricky
and i
was thinking one step at a time you know
i was thinking
very
myopically i wanted just to get
a good night rest a good night's sleep i
just wanted to change my locks
i thought i'd be healthier if i got some
sleep and i could think about what to do
or how to handle this
if i just could sleep and
when i did i realized
that that wasn't enough
that he could
get in any way
that the building wasn't going to stop
him
from getting a locksmith and coming in i
knew that he would
do what he wanted objection honor calls
for speculation
thank you all right next
okay
so
did mr deb show up for the hearing on
the dvtro
no he didn't did you
yes i did okay and why did you show up
because i had to provide testimony for
why i needed a restraining order
what if any warning
did you give mr depp about obtaining the
dv tro
um we gave him warning
my counsel and his counsel were in
communication and we let them know we
had to it's mandatory
it's my understanding of it i'm not a
lawyer
was there any confusion surrounding
whether mr depp was going to file suit
as well
objection honor
cultural speculation
lack of foundation right also to
foundation
did you have any confusion as to whether
mr depp was going to file as well
so i um
i filed for divorce uh on the 23rd i
believe
and i thought
that uh when i went in that tuesday we
or when we filed for it remarkably it
managed to stay under the radar you know
these filings are not private you can't
make them private in california
and remarkably it had flown under the
radar
no one picked up on the fact that i had
filed and
as limited as
it sounds now i just wanted as much
privacy as we could have you know one
day at a time i wanted as much privacy
as we could possibly get
and the filing had been missed by tmz
and
you know these paparazzi outlets and
stuff
but um
between the communications between our
council i realized that johnny was going
to
file in rejection
all right i'll sustain the objection um
i'm trying to think how to ask this so
um
without saying what the council said
what were you what was your
understanding and what was your concern
objection here i'll sustain the
objection
all right well let's move on let's
michelle can you bring up defendant's
exhibit 800 please
move the admission of defendants exhibit
800
any objection no objection your honor
all right 800 in evidence
amber can you
describe for the jury what this picture
is
it's a picture of my face while i'm
sitting at the courthouse
and were you wearing any makeup
i was wearing nothing not a stitch of
makeup
michelle can you bring up 801 please
move the admission of 801 no objection
801 in evidence publish
and amber if you can tell the jury what
this is
that's me while i was uh
obtaining my uh restraining order
it's me in the courthouse okay
and what if anything did you do while
you were at the courthouse
did you testify oh i i provided
testimony
and
sat there and cried
and did you obtain a domestic violence
restraining order
i did
the court granted me a restraining order
at that time okay
when you
left the courthouse
what did you experience
i walked into the courthouse it was
quiet first thing in the morning
uh no one knew about my divorce so
i thought it was gonna stay that way and
i walked out to a sea
of paparazzi and cameras
photographers
it was i
to that point hadn't i mean at that
point in my life had never seen so many
photographers and they just surrounded
me as i walked out of that
courthouse and
screamed at me screamed horrible things
at me
i'm going to take you just for a moment
to
make up and then we'll that would after
that
yeah that will be a big breaking point
after the makeup we said that you didn't
testify you uh didn't wear any makeup
that day we've heard all kinds of things
about makeup in this case could you
please tell the jury
what your
regular routine was with respect to
makeup
yes i get up and wash my face like most
of us and i put on
right away a moisturizer that has a
tinted foundation in it
and then i put another
foundation on because it has sunblock in
it i have a skin condition that my skin
reacts to the sun in a bad way
so i have to i have to wear sunscreen or
sunblock every day anyway so i put on
both of those i put on concealer
uh and i uh i do that before i i leave
my bathroom
in the morning
okay that's
obviously if i don't have a bruise now
when you had bruises or cuts of any
nature what would you do
uh about those would you try to cover
them up would you try to just leave them
showing what would you do cheshire honor
leading
uh well i'm uh
i
am typically photographed in la when i
leave the house a paparazzi
type of photograph so
uh i always
i'm you know somewhat aware of that
anyway um
and
no one want no woman wants to walk
around with a bruise on her face
so if i do have a bruise
on my face or someplace visible you know
the main thing you have to ice right
away to reduce swelling because no
amount of makeup can can fix swelling
but it's very manageable if you ice it
really soon
arnica is also a great uh remedy arnica
cream
and then if you want to cover up a
bruise
you obviously put
foundation first concealer and then on
top of that um
i used a like a
bruise kit not a bruise kit it's a
theater makeup kit a color correction
kit but i use i called it my bruise kit
and let me
i use this i think an opening statement
in its defendant's exhibit if you could
buy the
microphone please oh just we can't hear
you there you go
may i approach uh the witness to
that's what you could show the council
yeah this is what i was talking about as
a color correction kit this is not
obviously the exact one i used to carry
but i used to carry with me all the time
sometimes this pink is sometimes a
little bit more purple of a hue
and sometimes the kids are three colors
you can get them in three or four colors
sometimes they have even more but the
idea is that you want to counteract
whatever color you're working with on
the bruise so the first day of bruising
and
well the immediate is red
red is what shows up right away so you
want to go with the opposite on the
color wheel by
dabbing on a bit of the green or
something to counteract
thread
after a day or two you get more purple
in a bruise
so
you'd obviously have to go with more of
the red tones or the orange tones here
day two for me was always the trickiest
because um
day two just
i feel like well day one and day two are
hardest for me because that's when you
get the most blues and purples and
you have to
[Music]
deal with the sensitivity bruises don't
like to be touched that's the whole
point
um so that's the trickiest part but
after a few days that becomes more of a
that blue becomes more of a
a brown yellowish browns like a
you know five seven days and becomes
more of a yellow green
uh and then fades into a brown and then
into your skin
and you whatever color you're working
with in the bruise you want to go
opposite color on the color wheel
so
the opposite
i mean so in the first couple of days
when you have more of the typical
bruised color the blues and and the
purples
you want to go more of the orange uh on
the on the color wheel as opposed to the
greens that you start with and then it
move it progresses from there i also
noticed that
bruising on your face
tends to heal a lot faster than at least
for me it was faster healing than
bruises on my body or at least it seemed
like that to me
and um a nose is pretty much um
unrecognizable after a day or two
depending on how much you ice it
uh lips are the hardness because they
crack and bleed of course uh but it's
easy to hide with lipstick if you're a
woman or you know if you wear a lipstick
i suppose
you know we heard some testimony of
people uh in the week of may 21st to
27th uh saying that you didn't wear
stitch of makeup oh was that true
objection here say
overall
uh they just don't know what they're
talking about i always wear makeup
okay you always wear makeup i mean it's
part of my bathroom routine in the
morning you know wash my face i put on
moisturizer my moisturizer has tinted
foundation in it and i'm certainly not
going to walk around l.a
with bruises on my face
okay
i think all right ladies and gentlemen
let's go ahead and take our lunch recess
at this time again did not do any
outside research and not discuss the
case with anybody and we'll see you in
an hour okay thank you
court is still in session so please be
quiet in the gallery thank you
all right
and again mr since you're still under uh
under oath and testifying you cannot
discuss this case and to include with
your attorneys okay in your testimony
all right let's come back then at 1 40.
okay all right thank you 140.
all right are we ready for the jury oh
you have things okay
yes
what do we have
okay we're ready for the jury
all right thank you
seated all right your next question
yet i'd like to move the admission of
defendants exhibit 155
okay
that's the
makeup palette
oh okay any objection to that no
objection all right 155
evidence do we have it
i think it's
there we had pictures for
all right thank you all right 155.
155. okay yes ma'am thank your honor
michelle can you bring up
depp exhibit number 357 bees and boy
plaintiff's exhibit
and it is a tape recording from june
2016
the time stamps are 4
colon 47 to 7 colon 52.
all right is that in evidence yet i'm
going to move the admission okay so was
that going to be for the whole 357 or is
that 357a or is that that's just b b i
have that as a b as in boy i think there
was a portion okay 357 b any objection
to 357b
no your honor all right 357b in evidence
thank you
i can just tell you the basic facts it's
like it was private for days after i
filed
you did not have to file
that's not the move that one that other
that the other party asked me okay
okay and you did well you're a king did
okay then within
five minutes it was in tmz
you just do the math yourself without
any other thing and that's why it's very
clear okay and i i don't know if you
knew that
no i didn't know that and and
if that's the case i'll i'll oh i'll
acknowledge it
you know um and if you said you say yeah
then i'll acknowledge it look it doesn't
shock me the
if they file the [ __ ] papers tomorrow
which means
the [ __ ] i gotta file before we go to
court on friday
if they file
those papers
[Music]
it's first of all
it's it's
it's very bad
for both of us
okay
well you're people are firing that they
think it's bad for you trust me no
you're you're what you're saying you you
gotta do something to protect yourself
which means throwing me under the bus
for the
some video about me no
not me i have to respond legally with me
i'll have to go and pursue
the
no i could pursue the whole
course of action because here's what you
don't understand if
if we do this and well basically we'll
know because my i called my lawyers and
said why aren't we negotiating what is
going
and everything like that was all worked
out
though the thing that learning agreed to
was
she did not want to agree to a mutual
gag order
and that's the problem that she doesn't
want the gag or why johnny
why
why wouldn't she why wouldn't she want
both parties to not talk about this in
the press by the way just talking about
prep not even of course okay let's see
what remember
let me get on that right now i'll
[ __ ] get on it right now
and uh and i'll i'll get a message back
to you somehow just
you know uh
but i'll go i'll get on it right now
i just want you to know
i've not done anything and have not been
doing any moves like look it up timeline
nothing was on the offense everything's
been a defensive move because i'm being
called a liar and a gold digger and i'm
not lying about any of this [ __ ] and i
am not after a time of your money and
do you remember when you had this
discussion with mr depp
yes when was that i believe that was
june of 2016 so after
the divorce uh while we saw the
restraining order
okay
and what if anything was going on with
respect to a gag order at that point
objection calls for speculation
i i'm asking her i haven't overruled it
i
was i was trying to
um
i was trying to get johnny to stop the
smear campaign
objection your honor
hearsay
lack of foundation
what if any discussion did you have with
him about a smear campaign
johnny told me that he would ruin me
um that no one would ever touch me
meaning and professionally no one would
ever work with me again
uh that i'd never work again that i'd be
selling uh depends is what he said
uh
and that
he ruined my career
and
he refused to
um
not engage uh with
up until that point he refused to not
engage with the press by
uh leaking
objections calls for speculation
how is that speculation
this is what he's telling her correct
right okay all right i'll open the
objection
and up until that point um i was trying
to
you know uh get him to call the dogs off
call call it off because it was um it
was forcing me into position where he
was calling me a liar and he was forcing
me to prove it and i knew that wasn't
going to be good for him
and i i kept saying don't make me
don't make me prove it i don't want to
but he was calling me a liar and having
a really sophisticated very very well
paid very sophisticated pr uh machine
objection going over cause for
speculation
objection i'll move on um let's go to
dep exhibit that's plato's exhibit 357 c
that's 12 colon 30 to 16 colon 30.
remove the admission
any objection
no objection all right 357c in evidence
all right michelle to complain
i'm not
it's not about that it would not be
about me throwing on the device you know
what it would be it would be released
through
documented people
coming on the record and having the
protection to do so that i haven't had
yet
it would be eyewitness statements it
would be
evident
of
and it would be through years
and it would be
unbelievable
unbelievable
um to
imagine that either i mean a secret fake
club
you know for three years and while
taking pictures of it and documenting it
just saving it up for the right time
when i'm not asking for any money and
have nothing financial to gain from it
but no one is going to believe that no
one is going to believe that one of the
two alternatives either i'm gonna fight
club
or i've been getting going through hair
and makeup or going through makeup
through all these years where i have
cooperating text messages between people
that match those dates of those time
stamped validated
photos
of
of i would either cooperation between
people hearing us or cooperating
next day you know um witnessing text
messages having him responding or you
know the kind of stuff like between uh
me and people in your life it is
insanely qua across cooperated then it
is a plan i'm gonna put makeup on myself
and take pictures throughout the years
and just sit on it for years that that
well while having this like imaginary
life runs parallel to do you understand
that the pictures i have match with like
text messages to my mom back and forth
about it you know and text messages
between say raquel and my my mom might
we're telling my dad or you know um
between my two friends or there's a text
message where i tell jody the night
before i had that james corden night
show
thing where i say hey joey
um i've had an accident um
i
think i may have
i have a busted lift i may have a busted
nose and and um people have guys
tomorrow because
i don't
i know that will be in
and things like that
it doesn't matter
there is nothing there
nothing
and i will and all of that won't be me
throwing you on the bus
that will be evidence
in this
[Music]
case it will be criminal as well because
i cannot go on friday and file
without finally a big statement first
and the only reason i haven't had that
speech speaker which has been used
against me by the way every day
and the only reason i won't do it i
haven't done it because i don't want to
hurt you and that means it goes out of
my hands and every
third party guy a third-party prosecutor
comes and um and a criminal lawyer come
and they went like the problem is
hearing from you like your biggest
struggle is that this is just
this is such a it's the
most solid evidence
case that domestic violence has ever
seen and if you give this over them will
prevent any part of it
they will prosecute him and i felt like
i would
i'm not like i wouldn't ever
[Music]
can you please explain what the context
of this was
i was
begging
johnny to not
make me prove
what i've had to sit on the stand in
front of all of you and improve
and talk about
i was begging not to do this
not to sit where i'm sitting today
i didn't want this
i don't want to be here i didn't want to
be there then
and i was trying to point out
something to somebody who i thought did
not have a firm grasp on reality
objection calls for speculation
i was trying to point out
how absurd
how sword it would be
for him to keep making me
prove this
by calling me a liar i was trying to get
him to not call me a liar because
everything that i had said to date and
everything i said to date now is the
truth
and i was begging him not to make me
prove it that there were photos that
there were witnesses
that there was my testimony
there were years of me with
injuries
on the dates where we were fighting and
they were documented i mean
pictures from 2012.
so i was trying to say to him either
you'd suppose that people would rather
believe this is a hoax
elaborate
well orchestrated year-long campaign for
what
or that
[Music]
what it just seemed crazy
and i thought no one was advising him in
his best interest i thought no one was
telling him the truth
i know i was surrounded by yes men and i
thought nobody was saying to johnny this
is crazy don't do this
and i didn't want to hurt him i didn't
want to hurt him i loved him i loved him
so much
i that's why i'm explaining to him why i
didn't file criminal charges i didn't
file a police report even though it was
being used against me i didn't want this
to go to a prosecutor i didn't want this
to
hurt
johnny
i don't want this to hurt johnny
michelle can you bring up depp exhibit
357 d as in david
and that is 17 colon 25 to 17 colon 37.
i'm going to move the admission your
honor all right objection all right
in evidence 357d
okay
[Music]
i'm going to go on now to uh can we go
to plaintiff's exhibit 357 e
and this is 21 colon 47 to 22 colon
37. right i'm gonna move the admission
you're on any objection no objection
357e thank you
and you're stronger it's the way i think
that i thought you could kill me that
doesn't mean you count her you also um
that
[Music]
got crazy in the past and i truly
thought
i need to stop
this madness before i get it
i never think about myself that way i
never defend myself that way i never see
myself as a victim
you know all right yeah and i
i
when they came i did not cooperate with
them it has been used against me not by
the media by your side
and what are you referring to there
that i don't want to call myself a
victim i don't like to think of myself
as a victim and i don't want him to
think i'm attacking him or blaming him
i'm pointing out i didn't cooperate with
the police that i didn't
want to get him in trouble
but i didn't want to hurt him i don't
want anything from him just don't call
me a liar it's all i said just don't
call me a liar
just don't say this isn't real
because i'm the walking proof of it
i'm going to ask to bring up plaintiff's
exhibit deb exhibit 357 f as in frank 24
colon04 to 24 colon 48 and move the
admission all right any objection no
objection all right 357f
i have said all of this from the very
beginning i only have my integrity and
the unfortunate thing is what about mine
step further what about mine
every step of the way i have said to
them the thing is they're hurting johnny
by this because every time that they
call me a liar or they see this is not
true or see the business text message
does not actually happen or that uh your
security guard just by the way with the
follow-up to your security guard thing
they never saw abuse happening the same
security guards who by the way
have fed me
multiple times
that i was gonna get killed
and
what are you talking about there amber
that even though
johnny told me
that his guards would say
whatever he needed them to say
that they were the same guards who had
told me that i would lose traction
all right sustained objection it came in
through the tape so that's all right
we're fine
um let's go michelle
if we could approach please i'm sorry
michelle can you bring up dev exhibit
357 g plaintiff's 357 g and it's 26
colon 0 0 to 26 colon 28.
oh move the admission i'm sorry any
objection
oh obviously they're gonna have to say
they didn't see it in front of me and
other people that have heard them you're
gonna have to do this under oath too you
know
i will because i am unfortunate
i can talk about all of this do you
believe all this animal
[Music]
what were you referring to with the may
december and april
just listing some of the times in which
he beat me up
and that he knew about
so i'm going to take you now fast
forward into the july 2016 time frame
there was a mediation that came about
during that time
what if any intent did you have to
reconcile with mr deb at the time of the
mediation
i i wanted there to be no animosity i
wanted to minimize animosity i wanted to
reconcile in the that way i didn't want
to get back together with him that makes
sense
okay
um can you just briefly describe what
transpired during the july mediation
i
uh
even though i had a tro and i wanted to
move on with my life the
campaign i mentioned earlier the smear
campaign the article after article the
pounding me the
you know leaking
fake objection you're on and
non-responsive all right i stain the
objection okay
please explain what i was
meeting with him about is because he had
you know put these things out in the
media it seemed like actually your honor
culture speculation lack of foundation
all right
did mr depp discuss with you that he was
putting these out in the media objection
leading overruled out
yes
okay please explain
he told me he would tell his team to
back off and to
to
yeah to back off effectively if i agreed
to do certain things one of which
you know there was he wanted me to
like
drop charges he wanted or some version
of that he wanted me to
get back together with him and go on
tour with him in the tour bus he wanted
me to
do certain things that i thought were
impossible and that would definitely
go against
all of all of
you know
everything that i stood for and and had
earned in getting my my tro getting my
restraining order and moving on but i
had to break the tro in order to beg him
to stop the machine the press machine
because i was
feeling like i couldn't live my life i
was being dropped from opportunity
commercial opportunities people were
turning on me the
campaign i shot dropped me i mean it was
just i had never been inundated with
that much press every single day me and
my family were and every witness anyone
who even indirectly supported me got
bombarded
and the
[Music]
lack of foundation i'll stain just the
last the last part of that all right
next question okay
um
we heard christian carino testify
earlier can you describe to the jury who
what your relationship is it was with
christian carino
he was my commercial agent meaning he
handled things like campaigns
for a short amount of time and then
became johnny's agent around the time of
the divorce
uh
he was a kind of mutual friend at the
time between johnny and i and so he
helped
us kind of negotiate or mediate a time
where we could meet and my goal in that
was to just
beg johnny to stop doing this objection
non-responsive overruled that's right
what if any
desire did you have to return to mr depp
after the divorce
none okay
now you heard mr white testify that he
engaged in negotiations with you during
the settlement process of the divorce
what if any discussions did you have
with mr white
none i the first time i saw him was
on on the testimony screen uh in the uk
during the uk trial i've never spoken to
him so he didn't negotiate your
settlement no he did not okay
what was important to you in the divorce
negotiations
the the
the statement that was it the statement
i wanted a mutual statement
and i wanted him to call that you know
get the press out of this
just make a statement
and and and in that statement
clear my name i wanted to clear my name
it's all i have
i
you know i i i said this to him too and
you know he knew this
all i have is my name i come from
nothing all i have is my integrity all i
have is my name
and that's exactly what he promised to
take from me
why did you agree to accept seven
million dollars
yes your settlement
i didn't care about the money i was told
if i didn't agree to a number
that it could be overturned that this
would never actually
it would never get complete it would
never settle
right
what was your understanding that
if i didn't agree to a number it would
be overturned so i took
far less than what they were offering
and what i was entitled to
and why did you donate it to charity
i promised the entirety of it to charity
because i was never interested in
johnny's money
and in the divorce
i just wanted my safety i wanted to move
on from my life i wanted my future
and then he started compromising that
calling me a liar making it impossible
for me to move on
by doing so
so that i wanted the truth i wanted him
to clear my name and to leave me alone
i've been saying that since 2016.
so why did you donate 3.5 to children's
hospital and 3.5 to aclu
well i pledged the first half or 3.5 to
children's hospital because i've been
working there as a volunteer for
well over a decade
uh i knew the facility well i'd worked
there with another
non-profit is how i got affiliated with
them and i knew they could use their
resources i was familiar with it
and what about the aclu
and then
aclu because i was a supporter because i
believed in the work they were doing i
believe that they were
doing good work for people who deserved
it
why did you make the donations over a
period of time as opposed to just a lump
sum
two two reasons the short of it is
because i was receiving the settlement
in installments i was receiving the
installments over time
second of all so i could get the tax
benefit of paying overtime you know as
my understanding that's how you pay
these like large sums you pay it over
time
did you make any payments towards these
donations i did
okay
uh
approximately how much
i um
allowed for the first installment which
is a hundred thousand um to each that
came straight from johnny in 2016. i
followed up with uh 350 000
uh
that year
2016
2018 i did another oh and i also donated
to 250 000 to
art of elysium which is the affiliate i
was just speaking about
um that does the work in the children's
hospital
it was not going to count towards my
overall pledge but i did that too
and then i did another donation to you
each in 2018
and then johnny sent me 2019.
before we get to that i
did anyone
make donations to the children's
hospital or
aclu on your behalf during that time
period yes elon also
elon who was my boyfriend at the time
had his own charitable contributions
that he had that he made and he made 500
000 to both in my honor and my name um
in
2017 i believe
and have you completely fulfilled your
donations to the aclu and the children's
hospital i have not yet
and why not
because johnny sued me for 50 million
dollars in march
of 2019
and i have spent over 6 million
objection your honor
this is the motion of lemony did that
part was supposed to come in all right
once you come forward let's take a look
um
so going back to that then
could you afford to continue making
payments to the aclu in children's
hospital
no
okay
what if any intention do you have to
fulfill your pledges and donations to
these organizations i still
fully intend to honor all of my pledges
i would love for him to stop suing me so
i can
what if any deadlines are there on your
pledges and donations to the aclu or the
children's hospital there are none
they understand
okay
now let's uh let's go to defendants
exhibit 1458 which is already admitted
now i'm going to just direct your
attention to
paragraph 27 where it says neither party
has made false accusations for financial
gain there was never any intent of
physical or emotional harm amber wishes
the best for johnny in the future
what if any significance did that have
to you
that was everything to me that was what
that was the most important thing in the
separation agreement between us is
that he acknowledged
that
i hadn't made a single false claim that
my allegations were not false i thought
that just because he signed his name to
it he'd honor it i mean
he signed his name to it and i thought
it would mean something
he acknowledges that i never did it i
mean i never made a false claim and i
didn't do it for financial gain and
that's what i was being called at the
time a gold digger and a liar okay
thank you
we can take this down michelle and
i'm going to now take you to
post divorce and your career please
describe for the jury
how your career evolved after the
divorce which i think was final in
february 2017.
i
i had to fight really hard to keep my
career
i
you know after i got my tro i lost
opportunities i got cancelled from jobs
i got dropped from campaign i had shot i
um
was told i was going to be dropped from
objection honor hearsay
sustained objection i fought to keep my
job in um in a movie opportu the biggest
movie opportunity i had to date which
was what
uh it was justice league um with the
option to become aquaman it later became
aquaman
but i had to fight really hard to stay
even in justice league because that was
right around the time of the divorce
can you tell the jury what justice
league was and what your role was in
that
it is a superhero
franchise
dc action film
and it introduced my character
and
it provided uh the base
for the aquaman spinoff that followed it
but that was
not a reality at the time of shooting
justice league all right and then you
you were able to
be an aquaman is that correct
yes i
i kind of showed up to work months early
and
stayed really late
to fight to keep the job i managed to
keep it um
and manage slowly to kind of cro
to gain through this kind of hard work
and goodwill i was able to foster i was
able to keep and make other jobs and
eventually made a movie called aquaman
and
aquaman was very successful i think it
was a most successful dc film
um by its release and we you know i was
i was getting my
career back even though it was
you know it took a major hit when i
when i got my restraining order against
johnny
so let's talk about aquaman for a moment
i think you said it was the highest
grossing film of dc films is that
correct yes okay
when did that come out
december of 2018
okay
and what was your role in aquaman
i play mira
and was that a lead role
yes it is uh one of the leading roles
it's the female lead opposite jason
momoa's character of aquaman okay so you
were his
mate
you could say that yes i was his um
love interest the female i was a female
lead of the movie
okay
so in december of 2018 as aquaman's
coming out why did you agree to
participate in the op ed
well
because i
believed in some of the causes that the
op-ed was seeking to advance uh there
were there was a lot of attention and
energy around
um
gender-based
issues gender-based violence issues in
general i had just recently become an
ambassador
for the aclu
i was proud of that ambassadorship and i
was looking forward to the opportunity
to lend my voice to what i thought was a
great cause which is just a conversation
around
women's issues and gendered issues that
i think the whole country was having at
that time you know quite a political
conversation and cultural conversation
at the time and i was
happy to lend my voice if i could who
drafted the first draft of the op-ed the
aclu
did you initially want to include mr
depp by name or reference no
what were you trying to accomplish by
the op-ed
i was trying to raise awareness
around some of the issues that i just
mentioned
there was some legislative reform
uh
title ix being one of them
and there was just a greater cultural
conversation being
had around
uh gender issues and um
and i was happy to weigh in
um
on what i saw as a
the you know unique
phenomena that women and
typically women experience in our
culture when they come forward against
somebody more powerful
uh when they speak up about
gender-based violence and
i thought i could lend my voice to that
conversation
i thought i had something to say about
that
were you trying to boost your sales for
aquaman since it was coming out in that
same time frame
it doesn't work like that i don't think
any op-ed uh i mean
a major emotion picture major franchise
like that is not aided by the
publication of a
an op-ed in the washington post i'll put
it that way but the other way around can
be said you know i was
wanting to lend my name at that specific
time
to
potentially advance the causes within
the op-ed
because of your success as mira with
aquaman yeah just the publicity of the
movie and the success of the movie would
hopefully um
best case scenario um only add and lend
itself
to
would lend attention to the issues that
the op-ed aim to address
what did you do once the aclu had your
agreement to be the spokesperson for the
op-ed to put your name to it
i
sought the advice of my attorney
and why did you do that
because i
you know i didn't want to
get into any sort of legal issue
um i don't want to have any sort of
legal problems
for for
talking about
what happens to women when or people
when they come forward and speak about
these sorts of issues especially when
they come forward against someone more
powerful than them
and
that backlash the
retaliation that people face when they
come forward
is exactly what i was writing about and
i didn't want johnny to retaliate
against me
and quite literally prove my point
and
and so who was the council that you
hired to
review the op-ed
his name was eric george
where is he located
los angeles california how did you know
eric george
eric george is the attorney who
represented me uh in a different
litigation against those produ the
producers of london fields the movie i
mentioned earlier about having a body
double and sex scene that i didn't
approve of
what was your understanding of eric
george's experience and skills to be
able to review that op-ed for you in the
context of of your concern objection
speculation i'm asking her understanding
i'll sustain the objection
next question
did you have knowledge of eric george's
abilities at that time i did i thought
he had an excellent reputation and would
give me
great advice okay
and what if any experience what was your
experience with him and representing you
earlier
i thought he was a fantastic attorney
very smart and uh i trusted him
without uh going into the content of it
what if any uh of eric george's advice
did you follow in the context of the
op-ed
i took all of his advice
i made all the edits he suggested i took
all of this advice
and what if any of eric george's advice
did you ignore
none i mean he's my lawyer i listen to
him okay
i'm going to ask you
if we can pull up michelle plaintiff's
exhibit one
now this is the online
version of the op-ed and it has this
title amber heard i spoke up against
sexual violence and faced our culture's
wrath this that has to change
what if any role did you play in this
title
none
what if any role to your knowledge did
the aclu play in this title
none to my knowledge okay
are these exact words anywhere in the
article
no
[Music]
no they're not
when did you first become aware
of this title being included in the
online version of the op-ed
i think in this litigation as a first
time i realized that
okay
i'm going to now ask michelle can you
bring up plaintiff's exhibit two
this has also already been invented into
evidence here yes
um
and
this is the
on the paper version if you will of the
washington post
uh with your editorial and if you go to
the second page
this one has a title a transformative
moment for women what if any role did
you play in that title
i didn't okay
now
do you recall seeing this version the
newspaper version at the time
yes this is the version i saw i'm very
proud of it i had it framed
you had the newspaper version not the
only i did i had the newspaper framed
okay
and now i'm going to ask you
to turn to
michelle can we pull up plaintiff's
exhibit number three
and do you recognize this document
um
yes okay right now i'm gonna
i'm gonna move to admit plaintiff's
exhibit number three into evidence any
objection no objection all right three
in evidence if we can publish it to the
jury
thank you
now
is it fair to say this is a tweet
yes it is and can you explain to the
jury what a tweet is for those who are
not as social media oriented
tweet is a
a posting on a social media network
called twitter
okay
no did you send this tweet
i think so i must have okay
and what if any control did you have
over whether
the title
given to the op-ed online was included
in the tweet
you don't have can you don't have
control when you're retweeting something
i mean it's my
experience that you don't control a
title when you're retweeting something
you don't get a chance to
re-editorialize someone else's title
okay and and at the time you sent this
tweet did you
do you remember even noticing that title
i do not i don't i don't think i even
realized it
have you ever typed the words
from that title
no i have not
okay
now i'm going to ask you let's go back
to number two plaintiff's two
and i'm going to go
i'm going to ask you
what if anything in this op-ed
was incorrect
nothing
every word of it is true
and i'm going to direct your attention
specifically and if we can
blow this up just a touch
uh and move up just to touch michelle if
you can so we get to then two years ago
then two years ago i became a public
figure representing domestic abuse and i
felt the full force of our culture's
wrath
for women who speak out was this true or
false
it's true okay
what if any
thing did you do about speaking up about
domestic abuse two years earlier
well i went and got a restraining order
against my then husband
and walked out to a sea of media and
endured to that point two years of
vitriol
from the media and from
um johnny depp supporters
in retaliation for having done so
and i guess you're really answering my
next question which is and i felt the
full force of our culture's wrath for
for women who speak out
is that what you were referring to for
that next
yes because at the time um i thought it
couldn't be worse i uh obviously now
from where i sit today no it got a lot
it gets a lot a lot worse
and then michelle if we can move this up
a little bit further
well actually that's perfect michelle
then i don't have to use my purple again
then you said i had the rare vantage
point of seeing in real time how
institutions protect men
accused of abuse is this true or false
true okay and explain to me
what you meant
by that and
how that was true for you
i got a restraining order i
had to prove to a judge that i needed
one i had a bruce on my face i got a
restraining order i showed pictures i
had
proof and yet everyone
the media the the the studios that
you know both johnny and i worked for
they were ready to support him they made
statements in support of him they were
ready to fire me attempted to fire me
all right sustain the objection um
what if anything did you
witness with respect to institutions
meaning the people that we work for the
institutions we work for the studios we
work for decision makers in my industry
filmmakers and and and and
powerful people and decision makers
within my industry whom i had not ever
even met who didn't know anything about
what happened behind closed doors and
the marriage of johnny and i were making
comments about me statements about me
every i was dropped from campaigns i it
was
hard for me to work i was harassed um
i'm harassed on a daily basis death
threats
and just the
um
the fact that that wasn't uh there was
no parody uh you know the the studio
and um these decision makers and such
were so ready to support him and um
eager to to objection to honor hearsay
i'll sustain the objection right
so what if any ill will or bad
intentions did you have or intend
against mr depp
by assisting in writing giving your name
to this op-ed and then publishing it
none it's not about johnny
the only one who thought it was about
johnny is johnny
it's about me it's about what happened
to me after johnny it's about what
happened to me after i escaped my
marriage it was about me
and my life and what i endured once
i moved on and got a tro and moved on
with my life it was about what happened
to me after the only one who made it
about him ironically is johnny
i'm going to um we can take that down
michelle i'm going to turn to
something about electronics and
transparency
you have you've testified about and
we've seen photographs and audio
recordings and
text messages emails etc
what if anything have you done
to cooperate in the authentic
authentication of all of these things
objection your honor
may we approach sure
all right i'm going to turn to your
counter claim you have made a counter
claim against mr depp in this case
correct that's correct and it's based on
three statements that mr mr adam waldman
mr depp's attorney made correct yes okay
um
i'm going to
ask if you can pull up defendants
exhibit
245 but your honor i'm going to ask
do we have
it's already an evidence you're in if i
may approach if we can approach just
real quickly because i think we can move
this along faster if we do this ahead of
time
okay we're going to start
by bringing up defendants 1245.
all right moving that into evidence no
objection 1245 in evidence thank you
honor
and this is an article that was in the
daily mail
on 8 april
2020
if you see that and then michelle if you
can move that to the next page and
perfect
it says
adam waldman depp's lawyer said
afterwards amber heard and her friends
in the media use fake sexual violence
allegations as both a sword and a shield
depending on their needs
they have selected some of her sexual
violence hoax facts as the sword
inflicting them on the public and mr
depp
do you see that
yes i do
is this a true or a false statement
false
and why is it
false you'll have to use
to to use what i've lived through and
and and
and what i've survived
calling it fake
saying that that i'm i'm harming
johnny with this i'm harming the public
with this
this is what i've lived through
and to to say that it's a hoax that
these aren't even real things
i i i mean
after everything i've i've lived through
and survived and also i hadn't even
spoken
about
the sexual abuse within my marriage
i hadn't
i had been protective of that i didn't
want to talk about that ever
adam waldman was
the one who put that out in the world
as remarkable as that is i hadn't i i
protected that i had to go to another
country to give testimony and thankfully
they allowed me to do so
with confidentiality and some protection
and then
johnny through his lawyer
not only uses that against me but says
it's a hoax
thank you
now i'm going to
ask if we can bring up and it's going to
be 1246
a
and i think i'm moving this right
evidence as well no objection so 1246 a
is an evidence you can publish
and this is
an article that was published on the
28th of april 2020.
and michelle if we can
thank you
and this one says
depp's lawyer adam waldman
said
quite simply this was an ambush a hoax
they set mr depp up by calling the cops
but the first attempt didn't do the
trick
he told dailymail.com
and let's keep going
so amber and her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up
got their story straight under the
direction of a lawyer and a publicist
and then placed a second call
to 9-1-1 do you see that
yes is that true or false
couldn't be more false
and why is that
every part of it is false i
i didn't call 9-1-1
i didn't call the police i refused to
cooperate with them to protect johnny i
protected johnny
i didn't call them once and i didn't
call them twice i didn't rough up the
place i cleaned up the place i didn't
even know the second cops were coming
if i wanted to get something from him i
wanted a hoax johnny why wouldn't i
cooperate with the police wouldn't i say
something to the police
wouldn't i do more damage to the house
and
then just knock over the things that you
saw pictures of it makes no sense and to
do it in
online when there's no fact checking
there's no authorities there's no one
able to you know i can't respond i can't
i can't fight this and use these
sorts of media leaks and these comments
to re-echo over and over and over again
online with a network of people that are
intent on helping johnny through a
sophisticated pr machine objection
hearsay speculation
i'll sustain the objection next question
all right and so
what in fact uh
did you do that night
i
cleaned up
i protected johnny
i refused to cooperate with the police
like so many other people do
i tried really hard to keep it private
even after that even when i was
committed to filing for a divorce
i tried to protect johnny i tried to
protect the history of what we had i
tried to protect him
and did the opposite
and
i didn't i didn't even have a lawyer i
didn't call my publicist
i i i called
my contract attorney to to get me
another lawyer who could give me advice
on how to protect johnny
every bit of this
was to protect johnny and to protect the
secret that i had
fought really hard to keep for nearly
five years
which was
that behind closed doors
things were not what it looked like
okay michelle can you take this one down
and go to defendants 1247 please and
your and i'll move the admission all
right i know there's no objection 1247
in evidence
and amber this is another daily a mail
online and this is
published
on
24 june updated on 25 june 2020
and then if we can go
further
and this one says
depp's attorney adam waldman said
we have reached the beginning of the end
of ms heard's abuse hoax
against johnny depp
is this true or false false
and why is it false
because
unfortunately
all of this is real
and what i mentioned earlier about how
preposterous it would have to be
for this to be this elaborate hoax i
couldn't believe it i couldn't fathom
one day that that would actually be
legitimately the position that he
through a lawyer would take
albeit online where he could get away
with it for subjection calls for
speculation sustain the objection
and
why why is this so absurd
because
johnny and i lift this we lift through
this i lived through this and i narrowly
survived it
but i survived it
and you know i have
mountains
of evidence mountains
approved and yet it
it won't be good enough for people who
are seeking to make money off of
johnny's success objection your honor
calls for speculation
okay
so i'm going to take you now to the
damages that you've suffered as a result
of these statements by mr waldman on mr
depp's behalf
please tell the jury how you were doing
rep objections that's a legal conclusion
your honor
i'm sorry we moved to strike
council's testimony
uh from the record we'll disregard that
question all right your next question
what was your understanding of on whose
behalf mr waldman was making those three
statements objection lack of foundation
cancer speculation if you want to
approach again that's not what we just
said here
so we'll move forward to my other
question here
how were you please tell the jury how
are you doing reputationally before
these three statements were made
beginning april 2020 april 8 was the
first of them objection your honor i'm
going to object on lack of foundation
she can talk about her reputation
overruled all that
i took hard work uh
it you know
it took a lot of hard work um on my part
but i was able to work get my life back
on track um
i was taking care of my you know myself
emotionally my career i was working
really hard i was able to star in a
major success um
i worked on a tv series that i had been
attached to for a very long time
i became
an ambassador for several non-profits
that i deeply care about
i was doing a lot of really
you know it felt really good to be doing
the social work and the charity work
that i was doing and i was also filming
and working and planning on um i was
awaiting a schedule from
uh warner brothers for aquaman 2 the
sequel
and i had wrapped on that tv series i
mentioned and i was waiting to start
doing publicity for it to promote it
and i had a uh
a campaign a global campaign as a
spokesperson for a
major beauty brand
so things were you know
the trajectory was
positive
so
how
how did things change after these
statements were made
i remember around the time
unfortunately i lost my mother uh around
i mean on the first of april
and i remember it was uh when i was
grieving her that i uh got a
a call
that i should be expecting a script
uh for
my role in aquaman objection or hearsay
it's not offered to prove the truth
um so i was waiting i was awaiting a
schedule uh and a script for that
feeling concerned that you know i
wouldn't have enough time to to grieve
before having to get back into work i
had a press schedule to promote the tv
series i was doing and
i was
shooting things for this uh
beauty brand and then
uh
i i remember
at that time um the beauty brand
uh had to suspend posting what i had
what what i just shot for them because
uh they were getting bombarded
uh objection your honor this is hearsay
sustained objection okay all right so
they they said no i mean they suspended
what i had shot objection your honor
that she can testify to that your honor
she has to be able to
sustain the objection okay
were you were you actively involved in
campaigns for l'oreal before these
articles i was were you actively
involved in campaigns with l'oreal after
these articles no
were you with the stan you were talking
about the ctv series that was the stand
correct yes the tv series that i had
already completed all right and were you
actively involved in publicity
for the stand prior to these articles
yes i was were you actively involved in
the publicity after these articles no
shoots were cancelled things were
canceled um with respect to aquaman one
uh aquaman aquaman two you'd already
start in aquaman one right just so we're
and they called it aquaman at that time
but now there's an aquaman too just
right for that's correct okay so
were you
actively
scheduling
uh
timing for filming in scripts for
aquaman two before these articles
yes i was
were you actively scheduling after these
articles
no
the the communication stopped
um
at that point
all right i'm going
[Music]
all to michelle can you bring up
defendants exhibit 1258
i'm going to show you what has been
marked as defendant's exhibit 1258 it's
dated september 21 2015.
do you recognize this document yes okay
what is it
it is uh the justice league
aquaman contract okay your honor i'm
going to move the admission of
defendants exhibit 1258 any objection
yes your honor may we approach sure
so
amber can you explain to me
how that the contract structure was for
justice league and options just explain
to the jury please
it's
structured like a three picture option
you
i signed on to
do justice league where my character was
introduced
the fee is
you know small relative to what it will
become if
and when you do the other options or
movies
in that under that umbrella
so it was the contract for justice
league which could then become justice
league 2 or it could be aquaman or it
could be some other
movie within the dc
universe
and the second picture ended up being
aquaman
and then the third picture aquaman two
each time it the fee goes up but
objection order this calls for
speculation lack of foundation overruled
a lot
as far as the contract is concerned
that's what the contract says all right
and if we go to page six
so what was your fee going to be for
aquaman and what was it for aquaman
uh one million
okay then was there also box office
bonuses opportunities
yes i believe okay yes there are box
office bonuses if it makes a certain
amount in the box office you um you get
a
a bonus
okay
and it says picture number two
at the time you entered into the
contract and and uh with the on justice
league did they know what what the
picture would be no as i mentioned
before when you do the contract section
calls for speculation all right i'll
sustain that objection
okay
so ultimately what was picture number
two aquaman
all right and then uh what was it for
picture number three
aquaman two
okay and what was the fee
under the option agreement at that time
two million
okay
um
now did you have contracts with l'oreal
yes i did okay
and
can you just describe for the jury
what was involved with l'oreal you
talked about being involved in campaigns
and then not just just explain that to
them if you can as a spokesperson i'm
just involved with the brand as a
representative and a certain amount of
commitment
you have to
do throughout the year
on social media and on red carpets
promoting various products or
um
you know causes they're advancing
generally it's just like a brand
ambassadorship
okay
and did you
um well let's go let's pull up 1262.
and this is dated as of april 25 2018
correct
that's correct was that your first
contract with l'oreal
i believe so yes okay
and did was that for a term
a specific term
yes it was okay was it for two years
yes it says two-year contract and that
sounds right all right and then i'm
going to ask you to turn to 1264.
and that's april 20 2020
and what if anything did l'oreal do with
regard to extending your contract then
they extended it um they chose to extend
it with the option to kind of
all right and did they extend it just an
additional three months
uh
they could look at paragraph one
let's see
yes they did
okay and what if any work did you do for
l'oreal after these three statements
were made
uh
i have only been able
to participate in
i believe one
live event
that they also couldn't promote or use
the material from because of objection
your honor calls for speculation
now let's go to 1265
and this is
as of november 15
21 this is another
extension with l'oreal correct
yes it is and if you look at the second
option term under paragraph one it's an
extension of 20 months is that correct
that is correct okay and what if any
work have you been able to do for
l'oreal
since this ex since this contract
as i stated i believe i've only done
one in-person event with them and they
couldn't use the material okay
now i
let's talk about the stand for a minute
let's pull up 1263.
and this is dated july 3 2019
uh and i believe you indicated that you
had already filmed it by the time these
statements were made in april and june
of 2020 is that correct that's correct
okay and what if any marketing
opportunities were you participating in
prior to those articles
uh we had
appearances talk show
press the normal kind of group cast
press junket
promotional material photo shoot
um and i was uh i had
um
various publicity
engagements lined up like
magazine a magazine cover
um
that that sort of thing to promote the
film i mean to promote the series
and
what if anything
were you able to do with marketing
opportunities after the three articles
were published
uh
none
none
what if any
uh covers were you on after that for the
stand
they pulled the offer
for that so none okay and while we're on
this agreement if you look at the second
page
how much were you paid
for the stand
it's at six c
200 200 000 an episode
okay
now let's pull up defendants exhibit
1266
have you been able to get any work since
that time
i have done
one
small independent film okay and tell the
jury what that is
i shot a film in guatemala
it's a small independent
meaning it doesn't have distribution or
you know yeah it doesn't distribution or
anything it's a lower budget film
that i had been attached to for many
years called into the fire
okay
and uh 1266 has as of january 13 2022 do
you see that
yes okay when did you actually film for
this in guatemala
march
i believe it was march of this year okay
and do you recall what your compensation
was for that
i don't off the top of my head you can
look at alh
one seven six two eight it's paragraph
six a
oh uh
sixty five thousand
okay
and
have you
participated in aquaman 2.
i have
and tell us about that
i had to fight to
i fought really hard to stay in the
movie they
didn't want to
include me in the field objection you're
on or hearsay i'll sustain the
attraction um
did you ultimately were you ultimately
able to
get
to
film in aquaman 2.
a
very pard-down version of that role yes
okay what if anything changed in the
script
they took away a lot of objection you're
on earth you're saying i think she can
lock a foundation overruled as the
script
go ahead i
was given a script and then
given new versions of the script
that
had taken away
scenes that the
that that had action in it that had that
depicted um my character
and uh
and
another character
without giving any spoilers away you
know they're two characters fighting
with one another and
they
they basically took a bunch out of my
role they didn't
yeah they just removed a bunch oh and
what if any leverage did you have to
negotiate a higher salary beyond the two
million objections speculation
i'll sustain the objection what if any
effort did you make to
negotiate
a higher salary for your participation
i couldn't renegotiate my contract
and why not
objection this calls for hearsay
and speculation do you know why
still the same objections your honor
sustain the objection
um
all right
amber i'm going to ask you to describe
to this jury
the emotional
impact on you
of these three statements that we have
talked about these three counter claim
statements please describe how this has
impacted you
um
these statements are used
over
and over and over and over again
online
to
reverberate re-echo
and re-energize objection your honor
this is not responsive lack of
foundation
and here's the thing she gets to give
her causes
well her emotional the question was will
your emotional impact of these
statements okay
the impact it has on me is every time i
look at it uh which is every day
i
am set back i have to relive it
i have to
to have my the worst most painful things
i've ever gone through
painful memories i've ever had the
things i've narrowly survived at times
embarrassing intimate details that i
never wanted
to be known
never wanted to be public ever and to
have them used every single day to call
me a liar i have to relive this every
single day that i have to address those
claims
over and over again the most intimate
embarrassing
deeply humiliating and personal things
that i've survived
are used against me every day
over and over again
it's torture
i'm in so much pain
emotionally
i'm i'm i just
wanted him to leave me alone i wanted to
move on with my life
and he won't let me
by making statements like this he won't
let me
i have to be here today i have to be
reliving it every single time
he with these statements with these
these these leaks these comments
once again makes me
have to speak to the most horrifying
things i've lived through
it's torture
it's torturous why don't you have to do
that i want to move on with my life
i have a baby i want to move on i want
to move on i want johnny to move on too
leave me alone
thank you i have no further questions
all right ladies and gentlemen it's
probably a good time to go and take our
afternoon recess based on that so go
ahead and uh do not discuss the case and
uh don't do any outside research okay
we'll see in 15 minutes okay thank you
police court is still in session i need
it be quiet in the gallery thank you
all right well we just make it 325 then
we'll come back at 325. okay thanks
thank you
okay
so
all right
thank you
all right be seated cross-examination
good afternoon miss heard good afternoon
mr depp hasn't looked at you once this
entire trial has he
not that i've noticed no
you've looked at him though many times
haven't you
yes i have
you know exactly why mr deb won't look
back at you don't you
i do he promised you he would never you
would never see his eyes again isn't
that true
i don't recall if you said that
one of the last times you ever saw mr
depp was when you met him in san
francisco in july of 2016. right
that was the second to last time i saw
him yes
and this was after you had publicly
accused him of domestic violence
i got my restraining order before that
yes
and this is after you had obtained the
domestic violence restraining order
against him that's correct
let's please play plaintiff exhibit one
two two nine
um
for the record it's at eleven zero one
through twelve zero nine
i'm going to ask that it be admitted
into evidence any objection to one two
two nine
yes
all right one two two nine you want to
enter it in its entirety yes please okay
one two two nine entered in its entirety
go ahead and play your section
i don't understand is this what you want
no
oh no a hug is saving all this
please stop
[Music]
[Music]
and i will always do nothing to you
um
you will not see my eyes again
that's you and mr death in that
recording
that is
and this is from when you and mr depp
met in san francisco in july of 2016
right
yes that's what it sounds like that was
in the hotel we met once after that as
well
this is after you publicly accused him
of domestic abuse
yes and got my tro yeah and he tells you
you will not see my eyes again doesn't
he
uh yes he does in that recording and he
kept that promise hasn't he
as far as i know he cannot look at me
he won't look at you right mister
he can't
one of the first questions your council
asked you on direct is why are you here
do you remember that
i do
let's please play plane to exhibit 357a
which is already in evidence your honor
and for the record it's 21 22 through 21
40.
see what the jury and judge think tell
the world johnny tell them johnny depp i
find
[Music]
that's your voice on that recording
right yes it is
you were speaking with mr depp
yes
and you said to mr dab quote
you can tell
you can please tell people that it was a
fair fight and see what the jury and the
judge think tell the world johnny
tell them johnny depp i johnny depp a
man
a victim two of domestic violence end
quote that's what you said right
i was saying it to the man who beat me
up yes
i thought it was preposterous
and the man you beat up numerous times
right i could never hurt johnny
you're here in this courtroom because mr
dapp finally told the world that he is a
victim of domestic violence
i know that he is suing me
um and has sued
other people or corporations that have
said that as well
you didn't think he would tell the world
he was a victim of domestic violence did
you
i
found it hard to believe that he
could or that he
would do that considering the
relationship he and i had i i thought it
would be
crazy for him to do so knowing what
i know we lived through
or
as you said to him in that recording who
was going to believe that johnny depp
a man is a victim of domestic violence
right
with all due respect i wasn't saying it
because he's a man i was saying it
because he's a man who beat me up for
five years
mr depp is your victim isn't he
no ma'am
and once he left you you continued to
abuse him publicly
by calling him an abuser didn't you
he is an abuser and
you can look either of us up online and
figure out who's being abused online
let's look at some of that
mr depp wears rings on every finger
doesn't he misheard
that's my experience yes and they're not
delicate rings are they
no they are not
every one of his fingers is adorned
your words big
chunky rings isn't that right
that's my experience of him
and mr depp is always wearing rings
right miss heard
that's my experience of him
and you've never known him not to wear
these rings
and that's my experiences he normally
wore rings yes so mr depp
was wearing these big chunky rings
on every finger
every incident of abuse you've described
to this jury right i can't say for
certain it was in every single incident
but you've never known him not to wear
rings right
in general
my experience with johnny is that he
will he wears rings almost all the time
miss her do you recall giving testimony
in a deposition in this matter in uh
january of this year i do
can we please play
from your deposition
day 2
512 page 512 lines 11 through 15.
you said he hit you and he where he was
he was wearing rings right misheard so
he hit you with
rings on every finger i don't know if
i've ever known johnny to not wear rings
miss her do you testify to an incident
in march of 2013 where mr depp hit you
in the face multiple times do you recall
that
that's correct and you testified quote
you don't know how many times he hit you
in the face
that's correct
so mr depp hit you in the face multiple
times while he was wearing rings on this
occasion correct
which occasion and marcheri referencing
you weren't the testimony that you gave
on day 15 of this trial
march of 2013. you weren't specific
after the day
there were several incidents
the one where he hit you several times
in the face
uh
there were there was so i'm sorry just
so i understand better there were
several incidents in march which one are
you asking me about the time that he hit
you several times in the face wearing
rings
well
he pretty much in 2013
right
what are you asking me i'm sorry
he was wearing rings on that occasion
i pretty much always knew him to wear
rings okay let's please pull up
defendants exhibit 170
a which is already in evidence your
honor
you testified this is a picture you took
after that incident right misheard
yes that was one where he grabbed me
and hit you in the face so many times
that you don't remember
isn't that correct that's correct
and there's no injuries to your face in
this picture are there
not that
this picture shows
and there's no medical records
reflecting that you sought treatment
after this alleged incident either
i did not seek medical treatment at this
time
so there's no medical records reflecting
any injuries to your face after hit he
hit you several times i did not need to
go to the doctor at the time
despite hitting you several times that
you lost count with rings on your on his
fingers
that's correct i did not seek medical
attention
other than my therapist
you testified to another incident in
march of 2013
13 where mr depp hit you while he was
wearing a lot of rings
do you remember that testimony
yes ma'am and you testified you felt
like your lip went through your teeth
and it got a little blood on the wall
yes
i remember that
there isn't a picture of you with
injuries after that alleged incident is
there
i don't know if i've seen one um i i
can't recall there are a lot of pictures
you didn't produce any photographs after
that alleged incident did i i don't know
if i took one or if it's included i'm
not i'm not quite sure which ones you
didn't show any pictures to this jury
after describing that alleged incident
that your
teeth
your lip went into your teeth you don't
remember that right you show any
pictures to this jury after describing
that incident right
i don't believe i've seen that picture
admitted
that picture doesn't exist
i i don't know which one you're talking
about there were we have pictures from
march 2013 yes
the only picture that you've produced
and shown to this jury is the one that
was just
put up on the screen
where you said he hit you multiple times
in the face and you appear to have what
is a bruise
on your arm correct
i believe this is the only picture
that's in evidence right now
that's the only picture you've shown to
the story from march 2013 correct i
believe so
you testified about an incident in
russia
on or about june 26 2013 do you remember
that
yes that's correct you testify that mr
depp quote whacked you in the face
that's correct
and you went to the bathroom after that
right i did
and then according to your testimony
when you came out of the bathroom
jerry judge mr depp's security guard was
passed away
pointed out that your nose was bleeding
right
he did that in the hallway
and you said you hadn't known that your
nose was bleeding until jerry judge
pointed it out to you
yes that's correct i was unaware until
he brought it up to me i didn't see it
when i was in the bathroom but i wasn't
looking
so so it's your testimony that you went
into the bathroom
and didn't look in the mirror which i
assume was in the bathroom to notice
that your nose is bleeding
that's not why i went into the bathroom
i went into the bathroom
crying i don't even know if i paid
attention to the mirror i certainly
didn't enough to notice any blood
you didn't take any pictures of your
bloody nose either did you i did not
but pictures were taken of you in russia
though isn't that correct yes that
that's correct we had a press
or a dinner
um let's please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 1248.
miss heard this is a picture of you and
mr depp in russia
correct that's correct
i'm going to move to admit
all right no objection one two four
eight in evidence you can publish
and this is you and mr depp in russia
for the lone ranger premiere correct
it was a dinner function
i believe for in promotion of the movie
wasn't the premiere if i recall
you don't have any visible injuries to
your face do you
none that you can see
um let's look at plaintiff's exhibit one
two four nine
this is a picture of you isn't it right
that's correct
i'm gonna move to exit
admit
exhibit one two four nine all right one
two four nine in evidence
this is also a picture from when you
were in russia for the long ranger
premiere right that is correct
you have no visible injuries to your
face do you none that you can see
even though mr depp whacked you in the
face so hard that your nose bled
uh he did
while wearing chunky big rings right
that's correct
you also testify that mr dept again
walked you in the face after the met
gala in may of 2014 right that is
correct
you testified that you thought he hit
you so hard he broke your nose
that's correct
you said your nose was quote swollen
discolored
red
that is correct i took a picture of that
you testified you took a picture of your
face after this i did
you didn't show that picture to the
story did you i would like to
but you didn't show it did you that's
not up to me
you understand you were under an
obligation to produce all photographs
after any alleged incidents of violence
right ms heard i produced everything
didn't produce any photographs after the
met gala i produced everything
you also understand that you're under an
obligation to produce
all medical records reflecting any
injuries you allegedly sustained from mr
deb correct
that's correct and you haven't produced
any pictures or any medical records
reflecting a broken nose after the met
gal in may of 2014 have you
i have given everything to my lawyers
everything i've turned over literally
everything that i have is that your
testimony misheard that you saw medical
treatment after mr depp allegedly broke
your nose after the met gala not after
the met gala i did not seek medical
attention no
you also attended an event after the met
gala in may of 2014 didn't you that is
correct and you went to
the all-star comedy tribute to don
rickles that is correct that was the
next night after the met gala that is
correct and there were pictures of you
taken at this event yes
let's pl please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit one two five two
this is a picture of you miss heard
yes it is at that event yes it is the
night after the met gala yes it is the
night after mr depp allegedly broke your
nose
uh i'm not sure if it was broken for the
record but yeah you should see what it
looked like underneath the makeup
he whacked you so hard in the face you
thought you had broken your nose exactly
right
um permission to admit this photograph
all right one two five two in evidence
this is a picture of you mr deb and don
rickles right that is correct
please pull up plaintiff's exhibit one
two five three
this is another picture from that
evening right misheard
yes it is permission to
admit exhibit one two five three and
publish it
all right so mood one two five three in
evidence
this is a picture of you and mr depp
at the event the night after mr depp
allegedly walked you in the face so hard
you thought he had broken your nose
he did whack me in the face and i did
think it broke my nose and this is you
the night after yes it is
let's please pull up plaintiff's exhibit
one two five four
this is also a picture of you at the
same event correctness heard that is
correct
move to admit plaintiff's exhibit one
two five four
all right one two five four in evidence
you can publish
okay
and just to confirm now that the jury
can see it this is a picture of you at
the same event the night after mr depp
allegedly walked you in the face so hard
you thought he broke your nose
uh this is a picture of me um after he
did whack me in the face the night after
right yes it is i believe it was the
night after yes
your nose doesn't appear to be injured
in any of these pictures does it miss
herd
i'm wearing makeup
your nose doesn't appear to be injured
in any of these pictures doesn't miss
her
that's why i'm wearing makeup right and
makeup covers up swelling right
makeup will not cover up swelling ice
well though
ice will cover up swelling ice reduces
swelling normally the swelling after
that kind of injury is not as bad as you
might imagine and for me
it wasn't that bad
i have a picture of it underneath the
makeup that's how i know how to
reference it
a picture you haven't produced or shoved
into this jury right miss heard i
absolutely i've produced everything but
you haven't shown it to this jury i
would very much like to
it's not my job
yeah may we approach yes
ms heard you testified that in january
of 2015
there was an incident in tokyo before uh
mr depp's mordecai the film mordecai's
premiere is that correct that's correct
and you told this jury that on this
occasion
mr depp was kneeling on your back
that's correct in the closet you also
told this jury that you wore a backless
dress to the mordecai premiere that very
same night
i did
and you testified that you were
checking for bruises in the car
on the way back on the way to the event
to make sure that there
were quote no visible marks
right
i was checking on my phone
um
after the event to see to make sure that
nothing
they couldn't see
anything your testimony was that you
were checking in the car on the way to
the event
to make sure that there were no marks on
your back
perhaps i misspoke or misunderstood it
was on the way back from it was after i
was concerned after
you know concern that there would be
marks in any photograph since we were
being photographed at johnny's press
event
you didn't show this jury a picture of
you in that backless dress though did
you
i don't know what you mean i'm sorry you
didn't show this jury a picture of you
at the mordecai premiere
wearing a backless dress did you
i haven't had the opportunity to okay i
assume you have it
i do
um let's please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 1256.
this is a picture of you and mr depp or
the back of you
at the mordecai premiere in tokyo
correct ms heard that is correct
your honor i moved to admit and publish
this picture
one two five six in evidence
this is you in the backless dress at the
mordecai premiere in tokyo right
that is correct
you would agree that there are no
bruises or visible marks on your back in
this picture
no not that i could see
i'll show you
one other photo if we could please have
plaintiff's exhibit one two five seven
[Music]
this is a front angle picture of you and
mr duff at that premiere correct that is
correct
move to admit planche's exhibit
one two five seven all right one two
five seven
i'll show you one more picture
plaintiff's exhibit one two five eight
and again miss her this is you and mr
dad with the mordecai premiere
yes it is
move to admit plaintiff's exhibit one
two five eight
all right one two five eight in evidence
publish
and that's the backless dress right miss
heard that is correct
you also told this jury about an
incident in australia in march of 2015.
yes that's correct
you testified that after this alleged
incident you had cuts on your forearms
right
yes that's true
you testified that you had cuts on the
bottoms of your feet as well
yes that's true
and you testified that you had a bruise
across your jaw from when mr depp quote
clocked you in the face end quote
that's true
you didn't take any pictures of these
injuries while you were in australia did
you
i don't think no i don't think i took
any pictures
you just took two pictures of mr dutt's
writing on a mirror isn't that right
i believe so yes
so you had your phone on you right
at some point i did have my phone and
your ipad i had my ipad i believe
you testified that you were also raped
with a liquor bottle in australia right
misheard
yes
you testified you bled from your vagina
as a result of that sexual assault
yes
there aren't any medical records
reflecting that you sought medical
treatment for any of these injuries are
there
i did not seek uh medical treatment
after australia no not for the rape
no i did not want to tell anyone
not for the cuts
no not for the injuries to your face i
didn't need to
you also told the jury about an incident
on december 15
2015 right
uh where i'm sorry
december 15 2015. yes that's correct
you told this jury that after this
incident you had a broken nose
it certainly felt like it
just heard you recall giving testimony
on day 16th
in this trial
right
yes if you have
a transcript
for the jury or excuse me
okay all right
we'll get it
i will too thank you
may i approach the witness your honor
all right yes ma'am and would you like a
coffee yes please
if i can please direct your attention
miss heard to page
of day 16 4593
the jury trials transcript
[Music]
lines
eight through thirteen
on which page i'm sorry four five nine
three
yes
starting on line eight
i thought i probably had a concussion
and certainly thought excuse me let's
write that let's start over i thought i
had
i thought i probably had a concussion
and certainly that i had a broken nose
there was a blood everywhere blood all
over the pillows my head was bleeding
from the ripped out hair chunks of hair
on the floor all over the place actually
so lines
nine
that i had a broken nose
do you recall giving that testimony
misheard yes exactly
so you had a broken nose right that's
absolutely what i thought
had two black eyes after this incident
right
i did have two black eyes after that
incident
and you testified that you also had a
busted lip from when mr depp punched you
that is uh correct
from december yes that's correct you
testified that the lip wound kept
reopening when you moved your mouth
that's correct
you also testified that you had bruising
on your temple
that's correct
and bruising on your chin
correct
you also testified that your head was
bleeding from where mr depart chunks of
your hair out
i remember
yes and that you had quote gross [ __ ]
and quote bruising around your temple
uh in my scalp yeah
now for this incident you did take
pictures
that's correct
and we will look at some of those in a
minute but i first want to talk to you
about your appearance on the james
corden show
sure can i close this
sure
you appeared on the james corden show
the day after this alleged incident
right
i did
and that was december 16 2015.
yes that's correct
let's please pull up a clip of your
appearance from that evening if we could
plaintiff exhibit 35 and for the record
we will only be playing a portion of
this so we will call it uh plaintiff's
exhibit 35a
all right any objection
35a in
i evidence up you know in texas riding
horses and oh really you know it's not a
big ballet community out there in texas
no no not so much shooting guns yes but
ballet no
so i wanted to train for it and there
were some ballet sequences that that um
we wanted to have the option to to
incorporate into the movie so i trained
forever and i have two left feet i'm the
most klutzy person in the world and i
have no um what do you call
grace
your honor i'm so sorry
but it's not published to the jury if we
may have it please published okay thank
you apologies if we can please start
that over i'm sorry thank you your honor
i grew up you know in texas riding
horses and oh really you know it's not a
big ballet community out there in texas
no no not so much shooting guns yes but
ballet
so i wanted to train for it and there
were some ballet sequences that um we
wanted to have the option to to
incorporate into the movie so i trained
forever and i have two left feet i'm the
most klutzy person in the world and i
have no um what do you call
grace
i knew i had to train for it and what
they don't tell you i mean i i crammed
about three months of solid training in
and i'm kind of like working my way up
from the floor and learning the
technical aspect of ballet and i've got
these dances down technically perfectly
i'm learning all the movements but the
last thing we get to are the hands
[Music]
and i haven't yet got to that point but
everything else is working i'm acting it
up on my face and i'm selling the ballet
and i think i'm doing really good at
this point kind of nailing it
and so i send videos and and images to
my friends to like get encouragement
look for their support
and everyone shoots back what's
with the claw hand and i look and i
realize like all the stress and fear of
performing and doing this thing it just
kind of like
funneled out through the one thing that
i hadn't yet like what were your hands
doing so i'd be doing this amazing you
know i'd be doing up like a jump with a
back bend and you can see this like
graceful falling and my hands are like
and my face though is like i've got that
you saw in the cliff like this beautiful
1920s you know stage makeup on and hate
like
flower crowns and all this stuff and
then my hand and my face and then my
hands
that was you on the james corden show on
december 16 2015 right miss herd that
was
let's please pull up plan for exhibit
98.
these are pictures of you on the james
corden show on december 16 2015 right ms
hurd
they look like freeze frames um
like screen grabs
stills they're not like a it's not like
a photo shoot it doesn't seem but on the
james corden show correct from that
appearance yes
uh move to admit and publish plaintiff's
exhibit 98.
all right
you could move the microphone and turn
it on for you so judy and i are having
trouble hearing you sorry about that all
right thank you all right 98 in evidence
thank you
that's a photo of you opening your mouth
on the right right that's correct
and again a larger view of the same
photo on the bottom
that's correct
with a split lip
you've seen pictures of it without
makeup
i sure did in those photographs
absolutely
okay
you did take pictures of your alleged
injuries on after december 15th correct
you showed those to the story
i sure did yes okay let's please pull up
defendants exhibit 516 which is already
in evidence
[Music]
you testified that this is a picture of
you after the incident on december 15
2015 right
it was
and if we could also please pull up
defendants exhibit 517 which is also in
evidence
thank you honor
this is also a picture of you after the
incident on december 15 2015.
that's correct
if we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 409 which is already in evidence
these pictures ended up in people
magazine in june of 2016. isn't that
right miss heard that's correct
you gave these pictures to people
magazine after you publicly accused mr
depp of domestic abuse didn't you
i didn't personally know
this was you protecting mr dapp after
you got the restraining order against
him isn't it no this is him calling me a
liar and me forcing to prove it
as i mentioned to you earlier so you did
give these pictures to people magazine
no i gave these um pictures actually to
my lawyers and my representatives
at the time so it's your testimony
misheard that your lawyers and
representatives gave these pictures of
their client to people magazine in the
middle of a contentious divorce
i certainly did not personally give it
no
you also have a medical record from
after the december 15 2015 incident
don't you
a partial one yes you went to see dr
kipper's office a couple days later
that's right he wasn't in the office
can we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 47 which is already in evidence
this is your medical record for december
17 2015. isn't it misheard
that's correct
and this record doesn't document any
physical injuries on you does it
i i don't think so no i i don't think i
spoke
to kipper i didn't speak to kipper um
that day
and you went to dr kipper's office and
were seen correct i went to dr kipper
off went to dr kipper's office for a
concussion check right okay and this
medical record is from that visit
correct
partially yes
scroll down please if we could
the signature kipper down below this is
the entirety of the medical record right
mister yes what i meant by partial is i
didn't talk about what happened to me i
didn't get into my injuries i didn't
get into what happened or
ask for anything other than should i get
some sort of scan done
but this record doesn't document any
physical injuries on you does it
i'd have to read it in full but i i
don't know well let's do that
we could please go
well under skin on the second page
it reads intact normal color moisture
hair distribution texture
trigger
no signs of
oh this is going to be hard sienna sis
mottling jaundice
it also says i'm a well-nourished male
right
i have no idea what that means
i i think this
medical record is missing a lot of
things
yeah it doesn't document any physical
injuries doesn't seem to be documenting
anything
probably because there was nothing to
document right misheard i disagree with
you on that
you don't have any medical records
reflecting that you broke your nose
during your relationship with mr depp do
you
uh i
saw an ent after my relationship
ended
and you saw an e and it's your testimony
under oath that you saw an ent for
broken noses that you sustained as a
result of mr depp no but the ent told me
i susceptible objectionable fractures
i'll sustain the objection of
movement strike thank you
so again just to
try my question there's no medical
records reflecting that you broke your
nose during your relationship with mr
depp is there a misheard
i don't know what made it evidence but i
do know that i documented that visit and
that everything was given to my
attorneys
ms heard you never went to see any
doctor
or surgeon
to treat a broken nose during your
relationship with mr depp yes or no i
never sought treatment for broken nose
while i was with johnny
or after you were with mr depp as a
result of any injuries you sustained as
a result of mr depp afterwards yes i did
and you didn't produce those medical
records in this case i'm gonna inject
you on her she did
i didn't i i don't know
all right they have not been produced
yeah they've not only if you would do
some approach
you don't have any medical records
reflecting that you require any dental
work during your relationship with mr
depp do you
uh i don't know
i don't work i don't recall
you don't recall
one way or another seeking dental care
for any injuries you allegedly sustained
uh you asked me about if i had produced
records or if i had records that's a
different question
did you ever see a dentist or an oral
surgeon
as a result of any injuries he sustained
with mr depp
not
about any injury i had from johnny no
and you don't have any medical records
reflecting that you required any
reconstructive work during your
relationship with mr deb do you
i never required reconstructive work
so there would be no records
what you do have misheard are pictures
of mr depp's sleeping though right
the jury saw a lot of those
yes
richard let's take a look at defendants
exhibit 1090 which is already in
evidence
you took this photograph right miss
heard that's correct
and you testified that this was taken in
tokyo in july of 2013 correct
yes
so you decided to take a picture of mr
dub asleep on the floor
he was passed out
and i took a picture of him because he
uh wouldn't remember he claimed he
didn't pass out that way
and
sometimes security would
carry him like a baby into bed get him
changed
and he would be none the wiser so i
started taking pictures of it so that he
knew
that it was real that it had gotten this
bad
let's take a look at defendants exhibit
1091 which is already in evidence
you took this picture as well
yes
and this is the picture that was taken
in the bahamas right it's one of them
yes
and this is a picture of mr depp taking
a nap on his tropical island
i believe he
was on the nod but as he would say
sleeping on the nod on his island
they're very different in my opinion
and yes he is on the island
on vacation
uh we were on vacation yes
let's also take a look at defendants
exhibit 1092 which is also in evidence
we also took this picture right miss
herd that's correct i did
and this is another picture of mr depp
asleep in a chair
no he was um nodding off uh sleep is
different when you're nodding off
you're high on drugs didn't even feel
the cigarette in his hand that had
you know been burning on his leg
uh it was cause for alarm for me
naturally um because i cared about him
uh it's your testimony under oath that
mr depp is holding a cigarette in this
picture he had been
he seemed to really like taking pictures
of mr dot while he's sleeping don't you
i hated it
i hated it
let's look at defendants exhibit 1094
which is also in evidence
you took this picture of mr depp as well
didn't you i did
you decided to take a picture of mr depp
asleep with ice cream spilled all over
him right
he was nodding off and
i was worried about
how bad the medications and the
medication change and the drug uses had
gotten where he wouldn't even feel ice
cream or a lit cigarette on him and it
scared me
so you took a picture of it yes i um i
wanted him to get help and
johnny's surrounded by enablers who
clean up after him objection connor i'm
going to move to strike everything after
yes that she took this picture
still responsive here
the question was did you take this
picture all right i'll sustain the
objection thank you your honor
this isn't a very flattering picture of
mr depp is it no it's not
you wouldn't agree that this is or you
would agree with me that this is an
embarrassing scene right
yes i think it's a part of getting help
is looking at it
seeing it but you sent this picture to
one of your friends didn't you
uh i don't
recall
if we could please pull up defendants
exhibit 252
we'll only be looking at the portion of
this document so if we could please call
it defendants exhibit 252a
and for ease we've gone ahead and
redacted it
yes i was asking for support
that's correct
there's no question yet i must heard so
directing your attention i'm going to
move to admit
um exhibit
252a any objection
any objection
could you turn turn on could you turn
your microphone again i'm sorry
thank you
uh i need to see it first because i
don't know what they redacted 252.
redacted the
identifiers
and anything that's not misheard
text messages
consistent with hearsay
thank you
you remember we approached okay
sir does this refresh a recollection
that you did in fact send this picture
to your friend rocky pennington
yes i did
[Music]
he sent it to her
[Music]
on august 7th 2014 at 11 24 p.m correct
that is correct
so you sent miss pennington this picture
of mr depp with ice cream spilled on him
right that is correct and you wrote
quote this is what i've been dealing
with and quote did i read that right you
did read that right that's correct and
this is you protecting mr dub
that is me getting support from my best
friend this is you supporting mr depp
this is me getting support from my best
friend i also need support
you weren't afraid the the monster would
get upset that you took this picture
this was um opiate johnny
this is a different
version of him this is opiate on the nod
johnny and you weren't afraid that
opiate johnny or the monster as you
called him would get upset that you sent
this picture to your friend well he's
all of those things
he of course he could get upset and of
course that's scary to me of course
but stop you from sending this picture
to your friend did it
why would it
mr duff's
hand right hand is in his pocket right
misheard in this yeah that's correct
you also showed this jury
pictures of cocaine do you recall that
yes that's correct
please take a look at one of those if we
could please pull up defendants exhibit
167
a which is already in evidence
directing your attention is heard to
a photograph
this is a photograph you took in
march of 2013 right that is correct and
this was taken at your apartment in
orange
yes
and this is your breakfast table that is
correct
and it's your testimony that mr dutt
left this breakfast table
just the way you took it
that is correct
so this is what the table looked like
after mr depp had been doing cocaine
well clearly he has yet to snort these
lines
there are four lines of cocaine on this
table right miss heard
in this picture i see four lines
there isn't any cocaine residue around
those lines right
uh i not that i can tell no
doesn't really look like anyone's been
doing cocaine off that table does it
with all due respect i'm not sure you
know how that works
i'm asking if you do
you've testified you've done cocaine i
have
doesn't really look like mr depp or
anyone was doing cocaine off that table
does it uh i beg to differ with you on
that when you snort cocaine typically it
goes into your nose
and then it doesn't stay on the table
there's residue from that cocaine when
your lips and nose touch the table right
well the tampon applicator next to
the
credit card i mean um driver's license
that you see is
a device that
i believe my sister had taught him
to use in order to
put the cocaine
in your nose
mr depp is a pretty heavy smoker right
he is
and and that's a cigarette in the
ashtray in the back there
um back right yes it looks like one of
his hand rolled
there's no other cigarettes in that
ashtray are there i see one cigarette
the one that's not smoked
that's correct
there's no ash in that ashtray either is
there
not that i can
tell in this picture it's pretty clean
in this picture it looks like it yes
it's a pretty neat table wouldn't you
agree
um
depends on what you would call neat i
suppose
and you sent this picture to your friend
rocky pennington as well didn't you i
sure did
and when you sent it you said quote look
at my morning
or something like that is that right
yay for
mornings so you have a habit of sending
stage photographs to your friend rocky
don't you i had a habit of communicating
with my best friend about what was going
on in my life
you don't have any pictures of mr deb
actually consuming cocaine do you
i don't think i have a picture of him
mid snort
no
you don't even have any pictures of mr
depp with cocaine
what do you mean by that
holding cocaine standing next to cocaine
um
sitting next to cocaine
i don't know
i don't know
well you haven't shown any of those
pictures like that to the jury have you
i don't know i no i haven't
and you were never able to catch mr depp
with cocaine on film either
were you i never tried
but you were able to catch him sleeping
right
i have seen him pass out in
all sorts of places yes
and you also captured a video of mr depp
in the kitchen that was played again for
this jury today
beating up some cabinets do you recall
that
sorry say that again you recall
capturing mr depp in the kitchen of one
of his homes
beating up some cabinets
yes
slamming things around yes so you took
that video of mr depp in the kitchen
right i did
i did and you took it on one of your
ipad devices i took it on my ipad
you were deposed in august of 2016 in
connection with your divorce proceedings
from mr depp right that is correct
and you will recall that the video of mr
depp in the kitchen was released online
the day before your deposition in august
of 2016. don't you that's correct
you're the one who released that video
that's incorrect i flew in from another
place at the time i remember learning
about it when i landed
so it's just a coincidence that the
video you took of mr dapp was released
the day before you were deposed in
connection with your divorce from mr
depp i absolutely had nothing to do with
that i wouldn't even know how to do
something like that
you settled your divorce from mr depp in
august of 2016 right
that sounds right
and in connection with that settlement
you received seven million dollars from
mr depp true
that's correct
6.8 exactly
your settlement amount was seven million
dollars that's correct okay
and then you release a statement in
which you claimed you would be donating
the entire seven million dollars to
charity right that's correct
you stated you would be donating half of
the seven million dollars to the aclu
that's correct and you would be donating
the other half to children's hospital of
los angeles that's correct
and you also stated with respect to the
seven million divorce settlement that
money played no role except for the
extent that you could donate the money
to charity
yes that's correct
who could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 1259
this is an article entitled amber heard
donates johnny depp divorce settlement
to charity
read her statement in full
is that correct
that's what the title says yes
directing your attention to the portion
on the second page where it says
quote read the statement below
[Music]
is that the statement you released
misheard
that is correct
your honor i'd move to admit
the statement and the article as
redacted objection hearsay
it's her statement
it it this is not her statement this is
some this she just testified your honor
may i see the full
everything else is redacted
okay then i have no objection all right
one two five nine and evidence has
redacted
the statement reads
as described in the restraining order
and divorce settlement
money played no role for me personally
and never has
except to the extent that i could donate
it to charity and in doing so hopefully
help those less able to defend
themselves
as reported in the media the amount
received in the divorce was seven
million dollars and seven million
dollars is being donated this is over
and above any funds that i have given
away in the past and will continue to
give away in the future
did i read that correctly
that is correct i don't remember that
last line but i have no
it doesn't stand out to me is wrong
there's nothing inaccurate in the
statement not that i recognize now
mr depp donated a hundred thousand
dollars of the divorce settlement
directly to the aclu is that right
right at the beginning of the divorce
settlement he
uh donated a hundred thousand to each
charity
on my behalf or towards my contribution
so hundred thousand dollars to each to
the aclu and to the children's hospital
and in response you publicly demanded
that mr deb pay the divorce settlement
directly to you instead of the charities
right that was always the agreement
actually is for him to pay me directly
it was not his money as per the
settlement agreement to give away and
reap the tax benefit from
i said if he wants to do it and give to
charity all of a sudden then he should
pay
the correct amount and not try to get a
big tax break for it so effectively for
his tax bracket he should be paying
double that amount to the charity
directly and if you wanted to pay the
charity directly he could
he could do that was fine with me but he
would need to pay the adjusted amount
ultimately the rest of the 7 million
divorce settlement was paid directly to
you right over time yes mr depton and
end up paying the rest of the 7 million
divorce settlement directly to the
charities you identified that is correct
he paid the installments to me you
stopped that from happening didn't you
i don't understand what your question is
i'm sorry you stopped mr depp from
paying the charities that you had named
directly that is incorrect i said if you
want to pay the charities directly pay
the adjusted amount
or pay as per our agreement in the
settlement or in the divorce
as per our agreement
you also think he chose to do the former
not the latter i mean the other way
around
you also publicly stated that the 7
million divorce settlement should be
paid to the charities immediately in
full right
if he wanted to pay it in the way that
he was suggesting yes
and and you said publicly that the
payments to the charities should not be
drawn out over many years right
i said that
i don't i don't recall the exact words
that i use but basically that he
shouldn't use this as an a novel
interest in getting a tax break that if
he wanted to do that and not pay me the
settlement that was fine but he would
have to pay the adjusted amount and not
make it you know a commitment he would
not fulfill or try to avoid in some
other way
and that's because you wanted
the entire world to think that you were
donating every penny of the seven
million dollar divorce settlement as
soon as you received it
from mr dutt isn't that right no i was
going to be receiving it in installments
and i would be paying in installments
the donations
in fact you released a statement in
response to mr depp's hundred thousand
dollar donations to the aclu and chla
didn't you i don't recall
let's see if we can refresh a
recollection if we could please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit one two six zero
this is an article entitled amber heard
in johnny depp row over divorce
donations
and if i could direct your attention to
where it says i believe it's on the
second page
her spokeswoman responded in the
statement
the language that follows the statement
here spokeswoman it's not her right a
spokesperson is an exceptional honor
oh really you released a statement
we approach again okay
before we ask the next question i'll
just hand you a copy of this one i want
to see it before you ask me that's why
i'm saying okay that's exactly what i
said
your honor would you like to see one as
well no that's right that's fine thank
you
this is
could you please turn your microphone on
i'm sorry i was very happy
um
they gave me a redacted but i don't have
the unredacted to be able to see the
phone i plan to admit it or ask that it
be admitted in redacted form i'm taking
away any hearsay and i'm just trying to
lay the foundation but this is a
statement she released through a
spokesperson how would i know whether
there's more to it that shouldn't be
redacted your honor if i don't see the
full document
your honor the witness can testify as to
whether this is a full statement or not
the witness can't do we have the right
to be able to see the documents right do
you have a document that's not redacted
we can pull it up on our computers okay
just give us a moment your honor right
i can represent this is the full
statement that's reported
okay give an opportunity to look at the
unredacted one
thank you
so
okay
sorry may i approach it yes
so you're gonna can we have a copy of
this
you can get a copy that uh
later later today okay right i mean i
think she should be giving us copies of
the photo i understand but we'll take
care of that but okay as of right now
can we continue
we can hear but i have an objection
because of
there's some quotations missing okay
come forward
okay
all right
so directing your attention miss heard
where it says
her spokeswoman responded in a statement
language that follows her again she
can't read it she has to show the
language that follows
right
if you want a foundation to that good
you released a statement after mr depp
donated a hundred thousand dollars to
the aclu and a hundred thousand dollars
to chla correct ms hurd
i think so yes okay
and the language that follows is the
statement you released
in response to mr depp's donations right
i don't know if this is this the
official statement i really i have no
idea
the statement that reads
starts action your honor amber heard
yeah that's the only thing i'm going to
say would you please read that to
yourself it's heard
yes
did you read all the way to the very
bottom where the last word is supported
yes that's the statement you released
through your spokeswoman after mr depp
made the donations to
the chla and the aclu correct miss herd
i do not recall exactly
what my statement was
i don't disagree with anything in the
statement but i just simply don't recall
what the statement was we released is
there anything inaccurate in that
statement mr no okay i'm going to move
to admit objection you're on a lack of
foundation i'll overrule the objection
to what one two six zero in evidence
over objection thank you your honor
statement reads amber heard appreciates
johnny depp's novel interest in
supporting two of her favorite charities
the aclu american civil liberties union
for domestic violence and the children's
hospital of los angeles
this is great and unexpected news
and it continues
however
if johnny wishes to change the
settlement agreement we must insist that
he honor the full amount by donating 14
million dollars to charity which after
accounting for his tax deduction is
equal to his seven million dollar
payment obligation to amber
and it continues
we would also insist that the full
amount be paid immediately and not drawn
out over many years
anything less would be a transparent
attempt by johnny's council laura wasser
and patty glazer to reduce their clients
true payment by half under the guise of
newfound concern for charities that he
has never previously supported and quote
did i read that correctly
yes
thank you
after this you kept commenting about the
donation of your divorce settlement
right uh i don't know what you mean by
that
okay you spoke about donating your
divorce settlement on a danish tv show
correct
uh
i believe i said i had um
i believe i said i donated it to charity
but it was already printed or already
commented on and stated in the press i
had already
released that information in the press i
think i just confirmed it on that show
you appeared on a show called rtl late
night right
i don't recall it what show it was
if we could please play plaintiff's
exhibit 346 which is a portion of your
appearance on this program
and we would ask that it be moved into
evidence and asked for communication
it contains it's has hearsay contains
other communications with other
individuals your honor if we may
approach very briefly
so if we could please play and publish
to the jury plaintiff's exhibit 346
all right three four six in evidence
and actually were all kinds of
accusations uh flying your way when you
said all this and then there was a
divorce settlement you got seven million
dollars people were saying this is all
about the money but then you did
something that uh twisted that whole
argument what did you do with that money
seven
million dollars in total was donated to
and i split it between the aclu and
children's hospital of los angeles clu
is a human rights organization aclu is a
prominent
organization non-profit organization in
the united states it's called the
american civil liberties union and they
work on behalf of marginalized
communities
on the ground and legislative reform
and more power to you because that's
that's something that i've never wanted
nothing this interview was in october of
2018 right misheard i don't recall when
it was it was in 2018 right miss herd
i don't remember when this was done
this was after you had received the full
seven million dollars of your divorce
settlement for mr depp wasn't it again
without knowing when it was recorded i
have no idea
seven million dollar divorce settlement
was paid to you in full by february of
2018 right that's correct
let's take a look at defendants exhibit
1458 which is already in evidence
this is the deal point memorandum from
your divorce settlement right misheard
yes that's what it looks like
if we go down to the bottom of page four
there's a heading labeled
equalization payment do you see that yes
and underneath that it outlines the
payment schedule for the divorce
payments correct
uh yes well it begins to and if we go on
page
page five
so the first payment is scheduled for
august 31st 2016. and that's 200
thousand correct yes that is correct
mr duff's accountant edward white
testified that he made that payment
directly
you gotta turn on your microphone mr
huff i'm
not gonna hear you objection to her
testifying to what mr white testified to
that okay it said actually it he
literally testified to it in court all
over world objection thank you your
honor mr depp's accountant edward white
testified that he made the payment
directly to the aclu and chla correct i
believe so yes
and then the rest of the payments were
all made to you weren't they that is
correct
and the final payment of 2.3 million
dollars is on february 1st 2018 right
the final payment yes and you were here
in court when mr white testified the
payments were all made on schedule i'm
going to object to her testifying to
what mr white testified
objection go ahead thank your
honor and you were here in court when mr
white testified that the payments were
all made on schedule right
i don't believe they were uh he might
have not my question
my question was you were here in court
when mr white testified under oath
that all the payments were made on
schedule
i was here every day in court i heard
his testimony yes okay
so back to october of 2018
this was before mr debt sued you for
defamation correct
yes that's correct
he didn't sue you until after the op-ed
came out in december of 2018 right
he sued me in 2019.
and the op-ed came out in december of
2018. that is correct
so in october of 2018 you had received
your entire seven million dollar divorce
settlement you would agree with me that
is correct okay
and you hadn't yet been sued by mr depp
this is uh
october correct
so in this october 2018 interview you
said that you had quote donated
end quote your entire divorce settlement
to charity right that's correct
and in fact your exact words were quote
seven million in total was donated to i
split it between the aclu and the
children's hospital of los angeles end
quote
right that's correct i made that
statement as soon as i got a divorce and
we reached the settlement that's when i
pledged it right then
and you say this because you quote
wanted nothing end quote that is correct
but you hadn't donated your entire
entire seven million dollars settlement
to charity at that point had you that's
incorrect
sitting here today ms heard you still
haven't donated the seven million
dollars divorce settlement to charity
isn't that right
incorrect i pledged the entirety
of the settlement seven million to
charity and i've i intend to fulfill
those obligations
that's not my question
please
try to answer my question
sitting here today
you have not donated the seven million
dollars donated now pledged donated the
seven million dollars divorce settlement
to charity
i use pledge and donation
synonymous with one another but i don't
misheard
i don't use it synonymously that's how
donations are paid misheard
respectfully that's not my question
as of today
you have not paid 3.5 million dollars of
your own money to the aclu yes or no
i have not yet
and as of today you have not paid 3.5
million dollars of your own money to the
children's hospital los angeles correct
i have not yet johnny sued me so as of
today
you have not donated
paid seven million dollars of your
divorce settlement to charity right
i have not been able to fulfill those
those uh obligations yet
and that's because you did want
something
didn't you i didn't want anything and i
didn't get anything you wanted mr duff's
money
didn't get it wasn't interested in it i
loved johnny that's why i was with him
you wanted praise for donating the money
right
that's incorrect
you wanted good press
in general one
does want good press yes
you want it to seem altruistic publicly
wasn't my interest my interest is uh in
my name and clearing my name and
at the time i was being called a liar
and my motives were being questioned i
did see it as important to
clear that up i wanted to make a
statement to make sure that
there was not any doubt that i couldn't
be labeled these things just because
johnny was a bigger star and had more
publicity reach you wanted to remind
everyone of your claims of domestic
violence against mr depp right no i
wanted to move on with my life you
wanted to make those claims seem
believable
they are believable they wanted them to
be seen you wanted to be seen excuse me
as a noble victim of domestic violence i
have you never
never wanted to be seen as a victim
nor have i ever called myself one
you testified under oath that quote the
entirety of your divorce settlement was
donated to charity end quote didn't you
that's correct i pledged the entirety
no
misheard
my questions
your counsel will have time to redirect
you
after
you testified under oath quote the
entirety of your divorce settlement
was donated
to charity end quote that is correct i
pledged the entirety
i'm going to move to strike everything
after yes
all right
i'll sustain the objection and we'll
just move forward let's move forward
next question
under oath that statement wasn't true
was it misheard
i'm sorry i don't follow your question
sorry
you testified under oath quote the
entirety of my divorce settlement was
donated to charity end quote that
statement wasn't true
it is true i pledged the entirety to
charity
the statement when you say you buy a
house you don't pay for the entire house
i heard once thankfully you pay
miss hurt all right next question please
thank you
that statement isn't true today as you
sit here today is it
it is true i pledged the entirety but
you didn't donate it
unfortunately
you didn't donate it say yes or no i
haven't been able to obligate i mean to
fulfill those so that's a note right
i am i made the pledge i want to be very
clear i pledge the entirety i haven't
been able to fulfill those pledges
because i've been sued you had all of
the seven million dollars for 13 months
before mr depp sued you and you chose
not to pay it to the charities you
pledged it to is that correct i disagree
with your characterization of that
let's look at your sworn testimony from
the uk
all right yes ma'am
thank you
it's fast because do you want me to
close the shades
there's this light coming across them so
i appreciate them
probably good light
thank you all right
this is uh your third witness statement
that you submitted in the uk action
right misheard correct and this
statement was made under oath true that
is true i'm directing your attention to
the last page
of that statement
that's your signature right
yes it is so you made the sworn
statement on february 26
2000 2020.
that's correct and directing your
attention to paragraph four
it says
quote i remained financially independent
from him the whole time we were together
and the entire amount of my divorce
settlement was donated to charity end
quote that is correct did i read that
correctly yes you did
the hymn you were referring to is mr
depp
that is correct
most of the money that was donated to
the aclu and chla in your name came from
someone else isn't that right
i don't know what you mean by most of
well at least 500 000 that was donated
to the aclu in your name wasn't paid by
you right
uh i believe elon made a donation in my
honor on one one of the years yeah and
it didn't come out of your 7 million
divorce settlement right no nor did it
count towards my pledge
and at least 500 000 that was donated to
the children's hospital of los angeles
and your name wasn't paid by you either
right those were made at the same time
and it didn't come out of your 7 million
divorce settlement nor did it count to
my
3.5 obligation those 500 000 payments
came from your new boyfriend elon musk
right uh he i don't know if he was a new
boyfriend at the time
you got him to pay part of what you
promised to these two charities didn't
you incorrect
because you wanted to keep at least some
of the 7 million divorce settlement for
yourself right i'm very wrong about that
i think this
if you're honest okay this is a good
breaking point okay that's fine all
right ladies and gentlemen we'll stop
here for the evening remember tonight do
not do any outside research and not
discuss the case with anybody i know
these days are a little longer and i
appreciate your patience patience and
and you know in your uh taking care of
everything here please take care of
yourself tonight okay and we'll see in
the morning at 9 a.m
so
all right and again again mr since
you're still uh on the witness stand
please do not discuss your testimony
with anybody to include your attorneys
okay
all right nine o'clock tomorrow then all
right we'll see you now thank you
you